Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Doom 65!
Welcome back, master and mistress!
Howdy!
Howdy doody!
Hello!
Oh, I don't want to go into the demo mode!
It's been like looping for so long.
You know, if I just press star...
Okay, there we go.
I think now it will be fine.
Dropping this to say, howdy.
Howdy!
It's my birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Roku!
Happy birthday!
Oh my goodness.
We're like barely into the stream.
I already got a birthday.
Thanks!
Uma musume global release!
Wait, oh, that's not what you said.
That's what Virulent said.
Oh, thanks for manifesting!
Yeah, Uma musume!
Yeah!
Guys, I'm manifesting everything, basically.
Manifested Metal Gear.
Manifested Uma musume.
The world is listening to me.
Is Archives supposed to be on?
I guess it's fine, but I don't want people being delayed.
So I turn it off.
You come to the stream, you come for the very exact moment that's happening.
Thanks for letting me know, I didn't realize.
Can you manifest MGS Master Collection 2 soon?
Thanks.
Did you see that there was like, there were like, games coming soon to PS5.
And one of them was Metal Gear Solid 4.
And I was like, I don't know if I believe that.
Well, I'll believe it when I see it.
You know?
Can you manifest me million dollars?
I was watching a clip the other day of, uh, of Nero Sama playing, um, Who Wants To Be A Millionaire?
It made me want to play Who Wants To Be A Millionaire.
But, but, I kind of want to play it with somebody.
But it's also one of those types of games that, like, you can only play, like, you shouldn't play with other people.
You know what I mean?
Anyway, we're back to Doom 64.
The only thing they fear is you, Mint.
As they should.
Um, I have another meeting tonight.
You guys, I have three meetings today.
Holy cow.
Well, two of them were about, uh, two of them, the two this morning were for conventions.
Um, so...
But they've already been announced, conventions.
Um, but then I have another one tonight.
And so I was like, oh my goodness, busy, busy day.
So I gotta get through this game.
I gotta...
I gotta, I gotta, I gotta, I gotta get through it.
Manifesting Minto-gun.
Like, uh, like Dragoon?
Minto-gun.
Helping to see you at VTuber Expo.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Hmm.
So we must mint and tear.
Theocrass!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Excited for virtual vacations?
Yeah!
Wait, can I show you guys something real quick?
I moved, I moved some stuff around.
You're only gonna see my head here, okay?
Um, wait, hold on.
Uh.
There we go.
You're gonna, look.
I have an ad corner now.
Look at my ad corner.
I have an ad...
I was like, I think I should maybe do that because I have things to advertise now, you know?
There it is, virtual vacation!
Things to advertise.
Kind of.
Skip ads, stop!
At VlogNotWork.
I take back your birthday wish!
So, um, yeah.
These are events and things I'm going to and doing.
And the podcast.
Episode 13 went up today.
Yeah!
Um.
So, uh, yeah.
Other conventions.
And, and the such.
Is the birthday wish also sponsored?
Look!
It's a gift!
Thank you, guys.
Now that I'm indie, if I get sponsored, I get all the money.
So, you know what?
I've been a little busy bee.
Oh, a busy little bee.
No, I want to be a little busy bee.
Where it means I'm a little busy.
But I'm also a bee.
Good luck if you don't get stuck at the same level that made me give up.
Uh-oh.
So, I realize why the game has been...
Oh, hold on.
Let's load it.
I realize why the game has been...
Uh-oh.
It's time to go back to the begin.
And it's because, I believe, I'm on normal mode, but with less monsters.
But, you know what?
It's fine, because I'm having fun, so whatever.
You'll keep the money!
Oh, Oscar.
You're such an idiot.
Someone tell me there's a problem with my AI.
What's wrong?
My childhood.
Oh, Asgore.
You keep the money.
Use Promo Clip Boomer for a 10% discount on your birthday.
Oh my god, thankfully.
Thank you for the hot goes over.
This is a sponsored super chat.
I am the sponsor.
That is all.
Thank you.
Is that guy dead?
Let me know how the audio is, by the way, too.
I have to remember how to play.
Okay, hold on.
So... 2... 3... 4...
5...
6...
7...
8...
Oh, 3.
You killed him 5 seconds before a save.
Oh.
Wowee.
I have a question.
Does Doom 64... I know with Doom 1 and 2, the bitrate would be insanely bad while playing.
Is it the same with Doom 64?
Or is it...
Not so bad.
How do I stop running?
I guess I don't need to know how to stop running.
I just need to...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Are they coming this way?
Oh, they're coming this way.
They're coming this way.
Yeah, take that, bozo.
It has the audio.
Just let me know.
I can make it better or worse.
Audio's okay?
It's not too loud?
Thank you.
I hear more.
Someone's still throwing stuff at me.
How do I get up there?
Hello?
Let me in, please!
Rapunzel!
Let down your long hair.
How do I get...
Oh, there was a stairs over here, wasn't there?
Wanderblast, thank you for a whole month.
Thank you.
Oh, there's also over here.
Wait, hold on.
Let's see if we can take down...
What the... Oh, no, no, no, no!
It's a spider demon!
Maybe this thing would be better.
Oh, shoot.
Take out one thing at least.
Take it out.
Uh... uh...
Oh, they're
fighting.
Oh, shoot.
I got hit.
They're in fighting.
The girls are fighting.
Who's gonna win?
Uh-oh.
I think they'll win.
I took him out.
Ow!
Oh, my God.
What the hell?
That's so unfair.
Don't hurt me from here.
How... Oh, this opened up.
Overkill.
It's fine.
That was insanity.
I'm just taking all the bullets.
What am I hearing?
Okay, let's go upstairs.
MENTIONTAIR!
I had to un... make him.
That's...
Dogs may be able to look up, but Doom Mint can't.
How do I get to this thing?
How do I interact with stuff, actually, now that I think about it?
Was it E?
E to interact?
Yes.
Where are you?
Someone.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Is there a thing?
Oh, no.
I can't grip that.
Grab that.
E to believe.
I'm just going to ignore those.
Guys!
This is a...
Ow!
Gosh, I hate the lost souls, you sons of bitches.
What's five?
Nope.
That's not what I meant to do.
But you know what?
It works.
I'm at four!
There we go.
Raylan!
Thank you for the 50 gift attack!
Ow!
Thank you so much.
Anybody in here?
Some uglies over here.
Nice gifts.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Really do appreciate it.
Oh, this guy.
I just wanted to share that my family and I celebrated our cat's birthday today.
Happy birthday to your cat!
Can I get this guy?
He doesn't know I'm here, idiot.
Idiot!
Why am I hearing so many people?
I'm scared of that room.
It's a monster po...
Oh!
Oh my god, again?
Wait.
Oh, they're all stuck in here.
You activated my trap card!
Happy birthday to the cat.
Go, go, go.
Well...
Anyways, how are you guys doing?
Sorry.
Oh, good.
For some reason, I keep thinking they're gonna be able to hit me, but I know they're not.
I love old game limitations!
I'm sick!
I'm sick of you!
I'm just kidding.
I hope you feel better.
I'm sorry you're sick.
Sick in the head.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm sorry you're sick.
Sorry you're not feeling well.
It sucks.
Oh, there's a lot of guys in there.
Wait a second.
Let's get a...
Anybody left?
Nobody left.
Did I
get him?
No, I didn't even get him.
Oh my god, he scared me!
He really spooked me!
Ah!
Sorry.
It's always these guys.
These guys will actually be the death of me, I think.
These little losers.
Blueberry, blueberry, blueberry...
Ah!
Here they...
Oh, here they come!
Oh, oh, oh, oh...
Rip a die!
Am I even hitting anybody?
I can't even tell just die!
So many tomatoes.
Tomatoes.
A spicy meatball!
These guys are more meatball-y than before.
I can't get them from here very easily.
Let's get them from down here.
There we go.
That'll teach them.
Blueberry.
Hey, but we lost no health even though we got the blueberry.
Very good.
So that's gonna go up into there.
Sorry, I'm just trying to get my bearings.
Oh, this is water!
No one else.
Only a barbecue.
Those are some angry meatballs.
Yeah, these guys are pretty meatball-like.
I'm trying to grab their shotguns.
I'm too fast.
Too furious.
Spray and pray.
That is the basis of all combat.
I hate you guys!
But there is definitely some guys I haven't gotten yet.
If I don't want to leave yet.
Wait, also, how do I leave?
Wait.
Hmm.
Huh!
Curious!
Oh!
Yeah!
But there's some guys I haven't gotten yet.
No secret.
See?
You can hear them, you can hear them.
Where are they?
Oh no, this is where I just came from.
Hello?
Where are you at?
Monster?
Peter, thanks for the super chat.
Really appreciate it.
Oh yeah, like through here?
Check your map.
Wait, how do I zoom out again?
I'm gonna give one little run around and if I can't find these losers, I'm out of here.
Wait, what is this?
The golden cube.
Draco, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Also, this right here?
There's so much here.
And that back... Wait, I think I can get to that, right?
Hold on.
Wait, wait.
I got a super shotgun.
Oh, I already had that.
But how do I see?
I think I need to like walk along this, right?
How do I get... Oh!
Oops.
Okay, hold on.
I have really...
Pointless secret found.
I have really short legs.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Get up here.
Or really, bad balance is what I meant to say.
Oh no!
I think I give up.
No, I don't need a backpack.
What am I?
A baby?
Go up.
Lift up?
No?
Never mind.
What about over... Oh!
There's just some random pinkies running around.
What are you guys doing?
They're running around like they own the place.
Yeah!
They're like...
Where are the pinkies?
Oh, here too.
Okay.
Another one.
Another little...
Nice.
Where are the pinkies?
What is this?
I guess I think it's a rocket launcher.
And then this opens up here.
Ahh.
Okay, I think we actually got it now.
Let us leave.
Rocket launcher.
Have fun ripping and tearing.
Thank you.
Well, I thought I got some secrets, but you know, whatever, I guess.
What's this thing?
No secrets here.
Why can't I grab it though?
What?
What's the point?
Oh my god.
I just realized everything that's here.
Change.
Save?
Oh, thank you.
I shall save!
Yes.
Helloooo.
Helloooo!
AAAAAAAH!
No!
I got the chaingun!
LOL Hahaha...
That was awkward.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, everybody.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry, everybody.
I lost my whole blueberry in one room.
Red key.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
We're fine.
I would have bought gamer subs if not...
Oh, I wouldn't have bought gamer subs if not for your boomer code.
Ah, thank you for using it.
Appreciate it.
Maybe one day I can get a cup or a flavor.
Well, that was very cool.
Let's load the game.
I'm not starting...
this level.
Okay.
We know that that box in the middle is evil.
Evil, evil...
I don't even know why.
It does that.
It's so evil.
I saw a guy over there.
Oh, you can see them.
See, he's like kind of behind the pillar.
Okay, I'm just gonna go in with the chain gun though.
Shout out to that save reminder.
I know, I know, for real.
Whoever told me to save, you're the best.
Oucha!
Look at that.
Look at that difference.
The difference in everything.
But this like blew up, right?
When I got it.
I don't know why.
I'm just gonna leave it up there for now.
Okay.
Next room is also dangerous.
This couldn't be the level that people were talking about.
That's so scary, right?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh!
Ah!
I hear them.
Let's see how far they can go.
Here we go.
Let's go!
Take that!
Oh, I think he's dead.
Why!
Sneaky!
Sneaky skull.
Skull!
Even sneakier skull!
What the heck?
You fight demons good.
I thought this was like a berry.
I can't even see in there.
I'm going to go back to the chain gun.
Blueberry!
Blueberry.
How do I get this guy?
Wait.
Did I miss it?
Did I miss my shot?
Short king.
The guy doesn't know how to use his arms.
I don't think he's ever used them once in his life.
Actually...
I'm kind of confused.
How do I get out of here?
Now that I think about it.
I thought this was an exit.
But it's not.
Oh!
Sorry.
Did you guys see the Mata?
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
I didn't realize you guys...
Oh!
Here we go.
I understand what that was now.
Um...
Ummm...
Yeah.
Oh.
Actually...
we need more armor.
I guess this is...
Oh.
Oh...
Wait.
Can I get out of here?
Oh here we go.
Restart?
Oh shoot.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
In the meantime, they were able to reload.
Just watching it lower was so...
Okay, this thing explodes, doesn't it?
Oh my goodness.
I think I'm...
Shoot.
Shoot and kill.
Kill.
Rip and tear.
Rip and tear while I'm alive.
Oh my god.
I'm out of ammo.
This isn't so great.
I need to get this guy over here.
This heckin' dude.
Okay.
Now I feel a little bit more safe.
Well, safe is, you know...
Okay, we got him.
Oh!
We got him.
Okay.
Can I touch this?
Can't tell if it's lava or...
Where does it go?
I'm so curious.
Try it.
I think I can lick it.
Ria Kari, thanks for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Good, we got more bullets.
Oh, that's health.
Sorry, I'm just looking.
You think I can lick it?
Or...
Turns my gun red.
Feels kinda nice.
Actually, like, when I get really close...
I feel like I'm moving.
I feel like I'm actually going up.
Oh, okay.
Now demonic.
Wait.
Was there a switch over here or something?
Where's the...
Oh, here.
Here.
You guys are terrible.
Why are you in jail?
Give you the after credits scroll syndrome.
I know.
Yeah, you can see the buttholes like really clearly right now.
Like just gaping, gaping, gaping buttholes.
On all of these guys.
Oh, sorry.
My head's blocking the butthole.
Oh, ViviCore thinks you're the gifted.
Phyllis, welcome to Mamba Show.
Indecent exposure.
What if they're like the Romeo and Juliet of demons?
You know?
Split to the other side.
You.
Okay.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, I thought I killed you.
There we go.
Get his butt.
Why are all these guys in jail?
Not you.
You.
Wait, that's a big guy.
Hold on.
I got stuck on something.
Did I just see...
Did I just see one of those little skulls?
I think so.
Or I saw something, right?
Oh, ah!
Yes, I did.
Oh, my God.
You son of a gun.
I think there's one in there, too.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got him.
Oh, there's more.
Can I stop missing for two seconds?
Thank you.
I'm trying to strafe, but I guess I don't need to because he's slow.
Slow.
Slow is molasses, demon.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
Leave me alone!
I'm trying to kill another demon.
What are you so obsessed with dying?
Uh-oh.
The skull ain't slow.
Look, they were idols on the stage, actually.
I was just actually at an idol live.
Aim doko.
I don't know.
You're not...
You don't have to aim in Doom.
That's what...
Doom...
If Doom has taught me anything...
You don't have to aim.
Doom is automatic aimbot.
It's great.
Rocket launcher.
How many guns are you able to carry?
Right now, I have eight, I believe.
I need them both.
Hmm.
If I watch the idol show...
Oh, maybe they go down if I press the buttons.
You just point and shoot.
Point and shoot.
Point and shoot, man.
Oh...
Hmm.
Maybe I have to...
I'm scared.
Is there an order?
Ugh.
I have all the rockets I need...
Maybe if I do it from...
This one.
I forgot I had that.
No!
I have no more bullets!
I have no regular bullets!
Maybe if I do...
I still can't reach the blueberry.
How do I change to the other... Oh, here we go, here we go.
Right?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Next.
Blueberry, blueberry... Blueberry?
Run, run, run, run, run.
Get me out of here.
All speared up and ready to go.
Exactly.
I'm scared of this level already.
I don't trust it at all.
I don't trust this level.
I need more regular bullets.
Which one did I choose?
Wait, where do I go?
I pressed a button.
Opened up some... some... some... something.
Oh!
A portal!
Box of bullets!
We're back here.
How curious.
More bullets.
Bullets.
Many bullets.
Necessary.
Health.
Shotgun.
Take it, I'll take it.
I'll take everything.
What do you think are gonna come flying out of there?
I did not expect arrows!
Oh!
I thought it was gonna be a little skulls!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Come on!
Stop walking.
Oh, my god.
Oh my god!
I walked right into it!
Can you please hit once?
Can you... can you... I just... can you...
Oh my gosh, I'm not anticipating...
Oh, I got him!
That was exciting.
Oh, I... I went berserk-o!
Okay, it actually stopped.
Wow.
Aim doko.
Aim... Gosh, I wish I had a middle finger asset right now.
So I could say, aim doko!
And then give you a shiny bird.
Next outfit.
Speaking of outfits, you guys like Doki's new skin suit?
Where... Oh, I remember where the red key was for.
Okay.
I can't believe she threw away the eyepatch option.
What an idiot.
Did I go through here?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I do want that.
Um, I think I'm in trouble.
Maybe the Lin fight.
Maybe not.
Why'd you have to leave?
Come on, come here.
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
Oh, that was not a good idea.
You guys, don't do that.
That was not a good idea.
She's pitaco, just like you now.
She's actually medium, which is quite premium.
Why did I even hit?
I thought I was aiming at him.
Oh, my gosh.
The rockets are coming back again, even.
Again?
I'm getting sick of this nonsense.
Mint, are you for real?
What are you talking about?
What did I say?
What did I do?
I'm always real.
I'm keeping it real.
I'm always keeping it real.
Smash or pass for the Doom demons.
Let's go.
If that's too deviant...
What's FMK?
FMK.
Wait.
We went this way, right?
So now we go to the red.
Oh goodness gracious!
Leave me alone!
Oh, frick, merry kill!
For the doomed humans!
Oh, I wish I could have gotten another berry.
No, no, no, no!
Oh well.
Let's see.
Kill...
All the little baby demons.
Frick the spider monster.
Merry Pinky.
Blood keep.
Oh, kill the spider monster.
Kill the lost souls.
Yes!
Kill the lost souls!
Kill the lost souls.
Merry Pinky is the right choice.
Isn't it?
Just feels right.
Yes, save.
Oh.
There's lots of...
What's it called?
Where did you come from?
For real!
I'm always getting shot by those guys.
Can I kill more than one thing?
It's my frick merry kill.
I can kill whoever I want.
No, I don't want to go outside yet.
Is this a door?
Where did you come from?
You're medium, but Doki is now clearly flat as a board.
When she was like, wait for the...
Whatever the...
I really thought she was gonna...
Ouch!
Oh my goodness.
There's a lot going on here.
Okay, hold on.
I'm just doing circles.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I walked right into it.
I think I'm gonna die.
For realsies.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Was that a lost soul?
Was that a...
Oh no, it's just a regular.
I'm sick of these fellows.
Ouch!
I'm getting stuck on the tree!
Leave me alone!
Why won't you die?
There, I got one at least.
Goodness gracious!
What was I saying?
Oh, when she said, wait for the...
I can't even think of the word.
The reference sheet.
I really thought...
The whole time.
But she was like, wait for the reference sheet, you guys.
It'll change your mind.
Oh, they're all spawning!
That's what's happening.
Yeah.
I really thought, though, that she meant it.
Who's in there?
Can't even reach it.
She baited us.
I think it's really cute.
Really cute outfit.
So...
Um...
It made me think.
I was like, you know...
It's obviously very different.
There probably will be people who are like...
Oh...
It's such a big change.
You know?
Where are you?
Where?
It made me think, like...
You know, if I were to...
Oh my gosh!
If I were to ever change...
If like...
You know...
If you guys...
Would be okay...
With it...
I'm like trying to snipe with a...
Damn...
A damn shotgun.
It did from 1.0.
Well, I mean, like if I say...
Like a different mama or something.
I don't know.
Is what I meant.
Trying to get this guy.
Did I get him?
Did he die?
Please leave me alone!
They're just jealous...
Of my intact...
Bumhole.
Oh my goodness.
Leave me alone!
Oh, there he is.
He blends in with the dark.
Oh...
You guys know what I mean.
It's because they all have...
You know...
All their little bums are...
You know?
I need a red key.
What's in here?
Not a friend.
A foe.
Stop saying bum.
Sorry.
What else should I...
How do I address it?
I don't even know where I am.
I'm so lost.
Oh.
I'm so lost, you guys.
Gaping hole.
Did I just do something?
Oh, I need the blue key.
I'm so lost right now.
Okay, red key, blue key.
Is that red or yellow?
That's like kinda orange-ish, right?
Derriere.
Where can I get anything, though?
Box of rockets?
This seems like a...
This seems like a door.
Yeah.
Oh!
Look at that!
What did I get?
What did I do?
Huh?
Okay.
I'm going berserk.
Hmm.
Oh.
Pinky.
Interesting.
Okay.
I don't know what the hell is going on.
Ah!
Why?
Why are you in the library?
You don't look like you read.
Tale as old as time.
Song as old as rhyme.
Beauty and the...
Oh.
Okay.
I have to open that.
Beast.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
You're right.
I was literally telling that to people earlier.
Not earlier, but like...
I was like, hey.
You can't judge this.
You don't even know what it's...
Oh!
Okay.
Here's a yellow.
But where's the yellow key?
I don't even know where it's at.
And we gotta get... Oh!
There's the blue key.
Oh.
I go in here.
Here we go.
Oh!
Oh my god!
They're so blue!
I have to be a proper demon.
Demons are often teachers.
Oh my goodness.
Barely.
And their things are faster.
Hey.
Come out.
Dummy.
Where am I?
Where's the key?
Oh.
What's this?
Run!
Blueberry!
Oh my god.
We're fine.
Where's the key?
Key?
Coco!
Asoco!
Not Coco.
Asoco.
Coco.
Coco!
Asoco!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die for real.
Please.
I just got the blueberry.
Don't do this to me.
You're rude.
You're so rude.
No.
I just got the blueberry.
I just got it.
Coco.
Shoko.
Asoco.
What's over here anyway?
A blue door.
Oh.
I can't go through that.
That's probably the exit, right?
They're abusing the lost souls in this.
I swear.
Easy come, easy go.
I'll never have a blueberry again.
I'll never get one again, you guys.
What's in here?
This seems pretty...
Okay.
The spicy water.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
No.
I think I'm gonna be...
I think I'm gonna be in trouble here.
Nothing sus about this room.
Absolutely not.
It doesn't look like the ceilings will come down any second to try and crush me.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Remember if you're lost in doom, unlike real life, if people are trying to kill you?
You're going the right way.
What about the other side though?
Blue key.
What did I just open?
Oh.
I think it's just a rocket launcher.
Okay.
Here we go.
Run.
Easy mode.
Minto gaming.
Minto always gaming.
How do I get...
This way.
Not even a problem.
I have to be better about not being so hesitant.
But also...
I'm such a cautious gamer.
Such a cautious...
Maybe not even a gamer.
I'm a cautious person.
I'm a cautious ghost.
I've died once.
I don't wanna die again.
You know what I mean?
Did I get everything in here?
This feels like so...
It was yellow.
I don't wanna die again.
So... I just am cautious.
About...
Where I go and...
What I'm doing.
Anyway.
Dang.
He's just throwing them.
We interrupted the class, everybody.
Pinky, your husband...
No!
Also...
What's that over there?
Interesting.
Where are you?
Oh my god!
I didn't see him at all.
Gosh.
This level is pretty long.
Oh my god.
There's two of them.
Oh.
Never mind.
Nice.
This level is pretty...
What did I just summon?
Library is pretty stylish though.
It actually is very nice.
Right?
Okay.
Nice.
Maybe this.
Actually.
Pink muscles!
I hate you!
You are the pain of my existence!
Yeah.
Dummy.
Bozo.
Idiot.
Stupid.
Ugly.
Meatball!
I opened something.
It's okay.
You're allowed to bully these guys.
Okay?
Gosh.
How do I get that thing over there?
I'm so curious.
Sure.
Thanks for the super...
Hold on.
Oh wait.
Maybe I open like this?
Okay.
Oh come on!
There's something else I need to do.
Oh.
I think I did it.
No!
So unfair!
I was right here!
Will you play other boomer shooters in the future?
I'd like to.
Yeah.
Come on!
Gotta be quicker!
They got the gun!
Nice.
We got the plasma gun.
Which is good mostly to get...
So this isn't a door.
Interesting.
Okay.
It's good mostly to get ammo and stuff for it, right?
Now where do I go from here?
Did anything open up in here?
You're a super Inkiller!
Abnivore.
Note.
No Meatball Marinara subs for Minto.
Mintball.
Do I go out here?
Let's go down, I guess.
For some reason I keep thinking that's gonna open up.
Guys, I think I'm lost!
I think I don't know where to go.
I think I'm stuck.
This is where we started, right?
Why did I just open?
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
No.
Oh, there's lots of...
armor here.
I'll take that.
The map?
Go right of the blue door.
Okay, let me grab all this stuff first.
Right of the blue door.
Oh, what's this?
Yippee!
How do I get to the blue door?
Hmm, I think I went the wrong way.
What is this map?
Demons have no...
architectural sense at all.
Over here?
Oh, up here?
Maybe?
Thank you.
But also, no thank you.
We're just gonna blow him up.
Nice.
We just blew him up.
I like how it gives you more shotgun shells.
Because they're like, obviously you used your shotgun here.
Oh gosh.
It's gonna be more lost souls.
Please.
I'm saving the game.
I don't trust it.
I should be absolutely nothing.
I knew it!
Where am I going?
Wait!
I'm not that way!
This is so unfair.
No!
I'm so glad I saved.
I am so glad.
I saved!
I am so glad I saved.
Can you imagine?
You just had to stand there.
Oh my god.
ABS always be saving.
So true.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Wait.
Okay, I have to run through here.
Okay.
Let's go!
Do you think they ever just let...
that arachnotron...
in the cage out for walks?
Or does it just stay in there all day?
I think he just stays in there all day.
I think nobody wants to touch him.
Thank you guys!
Welcome back to membership!
Thank you!
100!
Let's go!
Entering Watcher's Step.
What do you mean by that?
Was this last level...
a hint at what's to come?
Hello?
Plasma gone immediately?
That's a little frightening.
It's worrisome.
Don't you think?
It's a little scary to think about.
Why are they giving me that immediately?
Upon starting...
There's all types of guns here, actually.
Okay...
A berserk?
I'll take it.
There's everything!
That's not a good sign.
Save!
Oh, thank you!
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
Save, save, save.
Yes, thank you.
I think they're trying to tell you something.
I think so, too.
Okay...
That reminds me...
Aren't you also a lost soul since you're a ghost?
You might fit right in with them.
That might be why they're so obsessed with me.
I'm probably, like, famous in this world, you know?
They're like, Whoa!
Phantom, the lost soul.
The ghostest with the mostest.
Uh-oh.
I heard them.
I heard them come in.
I heard them...
Where are you?
Not here?
The music is, like, even more...
scary.
Oh, there's the exit right there!
Good to know.
This is their weapon museum, and they're going to be stealing all the exhibits.
Maybe they're just, like...
One guy is just like, I told you we should be keeping them behind...
Oh, boy.
We should be keeping...
Why is they giving me everything?
This is really scary.
This is actually so bad.
He's like, I told you we should be keeping them behind glass!
Oh, there's a...
A white berry.
Oop.
Okay, I can't fall into the red either, right?
That'll be...
Oh my god!
Is he asleep in there, or...
What's going on?
Why isn't he moving?
Hello?
Ah!
Wait, hold on!
There's something wrong with him!
Hello?
I need a blue key.
Oh my god.
Oh,
that was close.
Oh, I got a blue key.
Oh, gosh.
There's two of them.
There's, like, five of them.
Oh, gosh.
There's...
Oh, god!
There's, like, so many of them!
I suck!
Hello?
For two seconds!
Blueberry...
I know this is, like, overkill, but...
Oh my gosh.
I'm just trying to get rid of some of them.
Please.
Okay.
BFG?
Wait.
Oh.
Let's go with this one instead.
The un...
Wait, hold on.
Let me think about this one.
I made a mistake before.
There we go.
Now I got them both at once.
The un...
Life...
Unmaker.
Unmaker!
Hey!
Where did you even come from?
I thought I took them all out.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
Oh, goodness gracious.
Is this guy awake yet?
Or...
We're just gonna leave him in there.
I think we'll just let him have his little nap and...
not even worry about it.
I want all this stuff.
I guess we can go inside.
Yeah, he's just chillin'.
What if I...
This is the best option, I'd say.
He has hair?
What?
What just spawned in?
What just spawned in this time?
Oh, okay.
Just you.
I can't believe he has hair!
It's like really long, too!
What is this decoration?
It's like really long.
Oh, I just realized I've been blocking my armor.
Let me scoot over a little bit.
Or...
I'll go here.
Sorry, it's always hard to find where to go.
Bald, bald, bald!
Ohayoumentai!
Thank you!
Thank you for the dough!
No!
Wait, who would win?
The strongest minty ghost maid or the weakest Brazilian male with RGB knife?
Well, isn't Sam the weakest Brazilian?
Or something, something?
So...
Oh, hold on.
Dang it, I really thought that was a door.
Are you sure?
Okay, here we go.
What the?
Invisible guy!
Watch out!
Oh, okay.
It was all in my head.
Okay.
Cool.
I imagine that.
Nice.
Oh!
Wait, no.
That's not what I wanted.
That's not what I wanted to do.
I wanna check if this is...
One of these are gonna be a door.
One of them has to be.
Where am I now?
I can't... I don't even know.
Where am I at?
Blue...
Blue armor!
Not blueberry.
Take your meds, minto.
I'm trying.
Oh, lost souls!
I'm
trying.
Oh, lost souls!
They're all doors.
They're just locked.
Do we hear anything else?
Now how?
Does this open anything else?
Or...
Doesn't sound like it.
Where do I go from here?
So many voices.
Whispering We're in wire.
Which is the...
Sorry.
That's from Pocahontas 2.
Which is like the most insulting movie I think I've ever seen in my entire life.
Where...
Actually though, where do I go?
I think I messed up the order.
Okay, hold on.
There was some place...
Okay, so we know that this one goes down and then it goes back up.
And then we...
I don't even know where I'm at here though.
Oh, dang it.
Come on, let me up.
Uppies!
Thank you.
Where am I?
Who?
Oh, come on.
There's a sequel?
Oh yes.
There's a sequel and it's all about...
Okay, so you know how like the actual history of Pocahontas...
Okay, well it's actually... I mean the actual history.
is like pretty dark.
But I mean like...
I don't think she ever... like John Smith was not...
who she married.
It was like some other guy.
And so in Pocahontas 2...
In Pocahontas 2 basically they were like, maybe we should be more historically accurate.
And they...
They kill off... sorry for spoilers.
They kill off John Smith, but not really.
And then they get her...
married to that guy that she...
Oh.
Oh, dang.
To the guy that was the real guy in history.
I'm actually so lost.
If anybody at back theaters know what to do...
I don't know what to do.
But then he wasn't dead and he comes back and he's just like...
You know what?
What is that?
He's like, you know what?
It's fine.
You can go be with that new guy.
That's just very awful.
It's like they almost...
It's like...
We do this every time.
Does something go up here?
What am I missing?
Historical NTR.
Kind of.
Confusingly, she marries a guy named John Rolfe.
And not the guy named... Yes!
Yes!
John Rolfe!
Check the map.
Wait.
Q.
I guess there's nothing else here.
Unless I want to get the...
The...
This stuff.
Unless I want to get the health bonuses, I guess.
Okay, let's go back to the beginning.
Let's go back outside.
There's probably like a whole army waiting for me.
Like how do I get in there?
But yeah.
It's just like...
Such a mess.
It's just such a mess.
Pocahontas too.
It's a bunch of losers!
It's a bunch of tiny demons!
Wait.
Uh oh.
They're cycling through.
I'm noticing.
They're going through like the easiest to the hardest.
Oh my god!
I knew it!
Why did you spawn on top of me though?
You jerk!
Next should be...
Oh.
Okay.
Why aren't you guys infighting?
He hit you in the back.
I need to be careful not to get trapped on the things here.
Oh my goodness.
I don't want to waste all my...
Oh.
Wow.
That was fast.
Now I should be able to get him.
Nope.
Who's next?
Oh gosh.
Oh god.
Five!
Oh!
Oh shoot.
Oh god.
Oh my.
No!
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god, there's a second one.
Instant karma!
What are you talking about?
Karma!
How is it karma?
What did I do?
Okay, nice.
They actually don't take that many hits.
Which is great.
Can I get another blueberry?
I got a stem pack.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
It's this guy!
Which is the BFG?
BFG!
The Cyber Demon!
Yes!
Guys, I died.
Where did I save last?
Oh!
No!
Oh no!
I'm really far behind.
Oh gosh!
Oh no!
I really messed up, you guys.
Have you ever tried avoiding the rockets?
That's a really good idea.
Let's see.
Maybe if we just rocket punch through everything.
Oh, we don't need to rocket punch through these guys.
Oh!
Like this guy could use a rocket punch.
Where's the other guy?
Here, you... Oh no!
There's some loss.
Oh, they're infighting!
Yeah!
Take care of them!
Those guys suck!
Wait!
No!
Take care of them for me, please!
Oh, that opens up a whole new can of everything.
Oh!
I don't know where I'm aiming, but...
Why did I do that?
Why did I...
I'm just gonna restart.
Why did I do that?
Why did I think that that wouldn't work?
Oh, goodness.
Okay, this is a bit of a... Okay, this is probably the most trouble I've had in this so far.
Which is fine, because so far it hasn't been so bad.
I mean, I know I'm playing on like, you know, not super hard, but whatever.
It's fine.
Why am I... Oh, am I okay?
Look at them just phasing into existence.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Calm down, buddy.
Can I touch the red?
Or will I die?
Why don't you infight?
Go after him!
He hit you!
It's rude as hell.
Okay.
Let's kill everything.
Before we grab the key.
I'm hearing...
Try walking on the red.
Oh, I think we're safe.
Okay, cool.
Oh, whoa.
Where did you come from?
I didn't even get the key yet!
Please.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Cass?
This is not good.
This is not good!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die here, for real.
I'm gonna die here for real!
Screw you!
Yeah, I used the BFG for this bit.
Oh my gosh!
I just can't get through!
It's such a tight area!
And the splash damage on the rocket!
Kids... heckin' me!
...only come out once I... once I got the key, which clearly not.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, screw you!
Ugly.
Got them both, nice.
Oh my god, he was waiting!
He was waiting for that!
He's waited his whole life to send the...
Nice-o!
Oh, that was close.
Oh my god, stop!
Stop it!
Are you kidding me?
That was... pretty unfair, actually.
I'm not gonna...
I am stuck!
How tall am I?!
I'm either two feet or five!
Give me... give me a break!
Oh my god...
You got the BFG 9000, oh yes!
If only I weren't so dang slow...
Oh, they're fighting?
The boys are fighting?
The girls are fighting?
Just let them at it.
Oh, uh oh, I ruined their fight.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even see that coming at me.
Guys, I'm not doing so hot.
What's wrong with me?
I've been playing fine this whole time and then suddenly...
Suddenly my brain goes to doo-doo.
What's happening to me?
I need more gamer subs.
Stop.
I can't tell if there's anything still here.
There has to be.
Oh, a hero.
Of all things, it's an invisible pinky.
Yeah, let's save.
But I will save... next thing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
There's some more left.
Where are they though?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Oh my gosh, there's more.
Even more.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, there's even more.
Where did they all come from?
What the heck is going on?
They're just spawning.
In mid-air.
Okay.
Now...
Now I think we're in the clear.
Okay, let's save again.
Yes.
They're no match for you anyway.
I'm the Doom.
The mint guy.
Okay.
Let's go shoot...
this thing in here.
Look at his hair when he turns around.
Oh my god.
Unbelievably rude.
What the hell?
Why didn't you die when I shot you?
I'm Facebook friends with the artist who did the sprites and animations for Doom 2 and 64.
Wow.
He said his goal was to improve the sprites and animations.
He used claymation.
That's so cool.
World's strongest imp.
Clearly.
Oh my god.
What?
An absolute...
What is this buffoonery?
I just cannot.
Okay.
They're all gone.
I come here.
And then some guy is going to spawn over here.
Wait.
Hello?
Doom guy.
Why couldn't you...
He's right in front of you.
Hahaha.
Okay.
That's actually how I truly feel right now in this moment.
It's like what I actually want to do to them.
I just want to punch him in the face.
Is there any more?
Is that it?
Can we get it out of our system?
Goodness gracious.
This way.
Oh!
Ah!
I lost so much health from...
I was at a hundred.
And that one...
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
That one shot from that...
Heckin grunt...
Grunt...
Made me lose so much.
Hello?
Where are you?
Okay.
Well there's health and stuff we can grab in here.
So we'll at least do that.
How do I...
Oh.
Here.
That's how we get up.
I'm going to grab the health.
And then we'll...
Like...
It's...
Here.
Yeah.
Grab this.
Shotgun guys are so deadly.
I know.
I lose so much health to them.
We lost to them all the time.
We'll go to...
I'm lost.
So we went to this one.
We're going to go to this one?
Most of the BFG damage comes from a shotgun like spray of tracers coming from the player.
Ooh...
Really?
Oh, dangit.
Dangit.
That, that's a no.
Oh, I'm at max armor anyway.
You know what?
I think it's fine.
Sorry, I'm gonna be save scumming here a little bit.
The BFG tracers only fire when the projectile hits something.
So they need to be in sight.
That's so inconvenient.
So first we got our little guys.
Did I... did I take a hit?
I can't tell if I did or not.
We're about to get to a cyber demon.
Our first cyber demon, baby!
Oh, imps!
Imps!
Wait, there's still a pinky!
Okay.
Yeah, take that!
Take that!
Take... oh, aim, don't go.
Take... oh, aim.
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
I don't know about you!
Now I'm feeling so good.
Do I even have time to BFG them?
I'm just running!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
I think... I think I got him.
I think I got him!
But...
I'm... I don't even know!
There we go!
Nice!
Just... run and shoot!
Run and shoot!
That's all I can do!
Wowee!
Wah!
Cyberdemon?
Where'd he go?
Where is he?
Oh my god!
I've had two health in a dream!
I'm not gonna make it, you guys!
Oh my god.
I'm not gonna make it!
Where's the health?
Stimps!
Where's the simp packs?
Use the unbirther?
I'm sorry.
Unmaker?
Oh my god.
Oooh!
Jukes!
Jukes like we've never seen them before!
If I make it out of this...
I'll...
I got an achievement!
Kill a Cyberdemon!
2HP in a dream, everybody!
The dream is real.
Maybe.
Let's go!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's open!
Wait...
If I walk in here, am I gonna die?
Greg does have one regret regarding Doom 64.
The Cyberdemons' horns look like dog ears.
They did look kinda cute.
It saved, right?
Just in case.
Okay.
Exit.
Wait, but what was the other spot?
Wait a second.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
I wanna see what was in the other area.
How do I get to the blueberry?
How do I get to this blueberry, then?
It's clearly through here.
Or the whiteberry, yeah.
The pearl.
How do I get this thing?
Just jump.
In math, let's see.
Yeah, it's behind that door, but I don't know how to open it.
Also, that... well...
I'm curious.
Very curious.
Rocket the door.
Yes.
I'll punch it.
Is it working?
What does it give me, anyway?
Does it give me health?
Is that a lost cause at this point?
Actually, it's a good thing we came back in here.
There is some health!
Wait, there's some health packs, you guys.
Wait, this actually might be good before we go to the next level, because...
Otherwise, I'm doomed.
Wait, get me up.
No!
How do I get up?
Oh, I think I have to run from here.
Hmm...
Interesting.
I thought the yellow one was invincibility.
Oh, it might be.
Gosh, I would have really loved to have that.
How do I get the thing?
I mean, don't waste it.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Let's grab the armor.
Or not.
Wait, where am I?
Okay.
Stop, please.
It's so sensitive.
Nice.
Okay, got some armor.
Invulnerability is green.
So, you guys were all wrong.
Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Okay, now there's that one, which is health.
Which I desperately need.
I know I'm like...
I could leave.
I could just go to the next thing.
But I just am so desperate for health right now.
I'm so desperate for health right now.
Okay.
Oh, come on, please.
It's right there.
Just grab it.
Grab it, Doomguy.
Grab it.
And you too.
Why won't you let me have you?
How do I get to this?
So...
You know what?
Screw it.
Let's just go.
I'm done.
Oh, wait.
I just went the long way.
But...
It's fine.
Help!
I need the synth packs.
Spawned fear.
I'm...
I'm very fearful.
The first couple of levels were like a walk in the park.
And now suddenly...
I'm feeling it, Mr. Krabs.
Oh, shoot.
Since when?
What hands do you have?
Mr. Skull?
This
is...
Oh my goodness.
I just slid down the door.
I don't even...
Oh, hello.
I didn't mean to.
I can't take a single hit, you guys.
Or else I'm so done.
Oh, there's a health pack right there.
Give it...
Who's yelling?
Ah!
Oh!
Such a lust for revenge!
Wait.
Actually, who...
Where did that shot come from?
Is that a guy in there?
No, that's a flame.
Hidden wall?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I caught a blueberry.
Wait.
We got a blueberry.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I can save the game now.
I can go over.
Fake wall.
Oh, fake wall, my beloved.
That's the exit right there.
Okay.
I'm full.
Let's go down here.
Is this a door?
No.
Okay.
Are those gonna yell at me?
Are those gonna shoot at me?
Oh.
Dang.
I got a secret area, though.
I guess I'll, um, remember that for when we need more.
More syntax.
What is in there?
Oh.
Just a decoration.
Gosh.
There are...
Oh.
There are, uh, decoration...
Design...
Interior design is so unique!
I hate the shotgun.
I hate the...
Blueberry...
Just walk
in the goo, you show-off.
Just walk in the goo, you show-off.
Oh.
Oh, the goo is gone!
What a strange room.
Need a red key.
I'm gonna change to this.
Hmm.
Okay.
Hmm-hm.
Curious.
M'kay.
Phew.
Thank you very much.
I hate lost souls.
Actually, I think they are truly my least favorite.
Okay.
Are these... oh wait, this one.
Oh, I thought those were things we could shoot.
Oh, hello.
Whoa, wait.
Wow,
I like this room.
Oh, um...
Okay?
Uh...
Huh... huh...
Hmm...
I thought that maybe this would trigger it.
Try when you're on a step.
Oh!
Go, go, go, go.
Yay!
Thank you!
What was I gonna say?
I knew there was something important about that step.
More than just being a little step stool.
Wait, can we also shoot the other ones then?
No.
These ones are boring and don't matter.
Sharp shooter.
Don't you know it.
I'm being really paranoid right now because of any loss.
Oh!
Oh, it's so good to be paranoid!
I love being paranoid!
This is why we're paranoid, everybody.
Has Ben played Doom at 16 slash Eternal?
I have not!
Not yet.
Yellow key.
Have I even gone down here?
I have not.
I saw one in there.
One more.
Oh, two more!
I love the way they mumble.
That!
Yeah!
Gremlin noises.
Oh!
Wow!
That's a lot of them.
Oh my god!
I'm not about to die here.
Wait, are these the stronger guys?
I guess they're the stronger guys.
Because they're still not dead.
There we go.
Holy
cannoli!
Pack pack!
Take that.
Cannolis are tasty.
Indeed they are.
Was that everything here?
Hmm...
Wait, this is the spot that...
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go down.
Let's go into this room!
Oh...
He was waiting.
He was camping me right there.
...
It's so hard to see the guys in here.
I think I got all of them.
For real.
I hate this game.
I hate this game!
I hate this game so...
...
...so...
...much.
I hate this game.
Oh my god.
Skill issue!
Go go!
Oh... no no.
I said go go, but I didn't think it would be like this.
Oh no!
I can't see anything.
I got a health pack though.
I could see that at least.
Uh oh.
As soon as I turn on this light, it's gonna be hell on earth.
Huh.
I mean it's already...
It's already hell.
Oh.
Maybe not?
Yes.
Maybe yes.
If you really want to prove you're Boomer Minto bona fides, then try playing Blood next if you dare.
I think...
I have not proved myself.
...
What?
Who am I trying to prove to anyway?
Huh?
You must prove yourself to be...
Oh my gosh.
I see him up there.
With his long, luscious hair.
Are you gonna come down?
You coward!
What the hell?
What took you so long?
Oh my god.
I just ran right into that.
...
Oh please.
Oh my god.
Ouchie ouch.
Ouchie ouch ouch ouch.
...
I'm stuck on the stairs.
Oh my gosh.
Oh the stairs saved me!
...
10 HP in a dream.
I feel like I'm not gonna make it, you guys.
...
I almost even fell into the pits of...
35 HP.
That's not as bad.
But, you know.
...
How much of... how much...
Oh, 500?
That's not so bad.
You can do it.
You really think so?
...
You really, really, really think so?
My armor's at 7.
...
Secret.
Oh!
I don't have to go back through the...
...main area!
Maybe this game is sometimes really nice.
Well, it really is an exaggeration.
...
This game is... kind.
This game has its...
...kind moments.
That's a better way to put it.
Now...
Wait.
You need a yellow key.
Oh, I just grabbed a red key.
I thought I grabbed the yellow key.
Wait, where was the red area?
Through here?
It was?
I've got to save it.
Sorry.
Save's coming.
A little bit.
Okay.
Say what?
What the?
What did I just hear?
Just heard someone.
Oh, hero.
Oh my
god.
Wait, I'm trapped in a corner.
Wait!
I'm trapped in a corner!
Please!
It was me.
That didn't even mean...
I meant to press not R8.
Okay, load.
I love save's coming.
Dead end, literally.
There we go.
We'll be prepared.
Is it overkill?
I don't think so.
I just died.
So, you know.
Lampy, welcome.
Thank you.
Very much.
I have lots of ammo.
And they give me more right here.
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait a second.
Do you see that?
Interesting.
Wow.
What a really cool room.
Oh!
Excuse me.
Can I get this armor, please?
Can everybody leave me alone?
Thank you.
Are you gonna play Uma Musume Global?
I would love to!
I'm scared though because I'm really bad about...
Oh my gosh.
There's so much going on here.
I'm really bad about playing more than one.
One mobile game!
Ah!
Oh!
Once!
Ah!
This was the worst mistake of my life.
Please die.
I know there's one more.
I heard him.
I saw him.
He went that way.
Oh!
But yeah.
I'm really bad about play...
Like I kind of put all my focus into one mobile game.
And I like...
I don't know.
Because I...
Just kind of...
I don't know.
Maybe it's like an attention thing.
You know?
It's like hard for me to focus on more than one.
Oh!
There's a blueberry!
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Where did you go?
There you are.
I hear...
Oh!
Hello.
Where the hell did you come from?
Nice suit.
Your hair!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Let's...
Nah.
Wait.
Yeah.
Let's just take them out.
And then...
No.
Oh!
Wait.
Where are they?
Souls!
Looking for some lost souls?
Oh my...
I didn't think it would reach through here.
Bring eye masks here.
Oh!
Yeah!
Really?
I'm so afraid of my favorite stuff coming over.
Like, I love blue archive.
I try not to spend too much money on it.
I think I'm usually pretty okay.
I'm usually pretty good... about spending...
I spend, like...
Overkill, but that's okay.
Oh my god, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Please!
PLEASE Where are you?
I'm trying to speak to my chat.
Could you all stop for five seconds?
Anyway, what was I saying?
No ammo.
I spend maybe like less than ten dollars a month.
They have like a special month pack.
So, I spend like... and I did that... oh, oh, oh, oh, goodness, oh my god.
Oh, but yes, that's what I wanted.
He just came out of nowhere.
I hear another one.
I don't know what I hear.
What did I just touch?
Monthly PA... stop!
It's just... it's tough to like get you more jammies and...
But I never spend like on the jammie packs themselves, you know?
Nice.
I'm typically pretty good with gacha stuff.
I'm pretty good about not...
Oh wait, this is where we came from.
About not spending such an insane amount.
Because also, I would feel so guilty.
I think.
In that like...
Wait, huh?
Go down?
Oh!
I would feel guilty in that!
I'd be like...
I don't know.
Gameplay is not for me in Blue Archive?
That's okay.
I think.
I'd rather spend money on cute derpy Yoshi.
See ya!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die in here.
Wait, I'm gonna die in here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Please!
Oh my gosh.
I would feel guilty because, you know, if I got my money through like a conventional means, then I wouldn't feel guilty.
But I don't.
And so I feel like it's a waste.
Of the money I do receive from you guys.
So that's why I'm trying to be even more cautious and careful about it.
Because, yeah.
It's your allowance?
No!
But I bought...
Okay.
But I bought a bunch of Metal Gear stuff.
I messaged Maddie.
Who she does, um, Metal Gear comics.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
I messaged her because I was on Mercari.
And I was looking and I found...
What is this?
Oh, my eyes!
Wait.
If I have this, please let me in!
Where do I go with the radiation shield?
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me in, let me in.
Um, hold on.
Uh-huh.
Um, they...
I've been looking for this figure for such a long time.
And it's a Metal Gear Solid 4 snake.
Like, old snake.
And his ass is just really, really fat in the figure.
So I've been looking for it and I found it.
And I was like, Maddie, I found the figure!
Finally came up on Mercari!
And she was like, yippee!
And sent me a bunch of, um, big butt snake emotes.
Um, anyway.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, wait.
No.
I don't think I'm supposed to go back to the acid room.
Go down where the poison floor is.
What's the poison floor?
Wait, like that one room?
Or the room...
The floor wasn't poison though.
It was on fire.
Snake with the fat dumpy fuzz.
Thank you.
He's like...
He's like in the...
In the pose, you know?
Where he's like, you know, he looks kind of like Spider-Man.
But his ass is just really, really, really big.
The red lava has progress.
The one over here?
Oh, I think...
I think I see what you mean.
Oh, oh no!
I wasted it.
Uh-oh.
Am I gonna be okay?
I don't even know where it is.
This room.
This here.
I have to do all of this.
Wait, no.
I don't have to do it all over again.
Though there was an entrance.
Oh, there was an entrance.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Do I have to do this all over again?
The yellow pillars.
You guys, I can't get it...
Oh.
My bad.
Oh my god.
No!
Lampy, thanks for the gift.
Dead!
No!
Who's your favorite?
Oh, who are your favorite Blue Archive characters?
I love Cherino.
I love Koharu.
I love Shiroko.
I love...
I know.
I love Erona.
I love Erona...
Erona.
Um...
Check for a switch.
Oh, that's a good idea.
I don't see one right here.
I think it's just a skill issue.
See, that was just a skill issue after all.
Oh, come on, man!
Let me at least heal!
Of course there's two of them.
You freaks travel in packs!
You're just like girls who have to go to the bathroom!
You can never be by yourself!
Oh my goodness.
Oh, I'm not even hitting him.
Oh, how did I miss that?
Can you just die already?
I thought he was going to be dead after that hit.
I need some health.
We finally have our yellow key.
Which means we can finally get to the exit.
Switch to the good shot, Glenn.
Wait, what are you talking about?
I was on the good shot.
Was I on the bad shot?
No, I was on the shotgun.
I was on the good shotgun.
Shut up, mod.
This is not the super shotgun.
Oh, I switched to it on accident.
Okay.
Alright, let's get out of here.
And be paranoid on the way back.
Paranoid, I'm paranoid!
I'm paranoid, I'm...
I'm paranoid!
I'm so glad I'm paranoid.
Oh, they're all gone.
I thought something opened.
Oh my god, no way.
No way.
Get me out of this, please.
I never asked to be the doom guy, please.
I never asked to be the doom guy!
AHHHH!
There's a secret exit.
Where at?
In here?
Wait, hold on.
Am I hearing a...
Oh, is that a door?
Is that what I'm hearing?
AHHHH!
Wait a second!
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I don't know if...
Is that it?
Okay.
That might be it.
Come on!
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
Run, run, run, run, run!
No!
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Please, please, please.
Secret!
Oh.
That was the secret.
80% secret.
30 minutes.
Oh my gosh.
In the void!
Oh.
You wretch is a strange...
Asrid...
Acid...
A...
Asrid...
Odorous salt seal.
Death and demon carcass!
No nightmare could have prepared you for this.
You realize that this place was not meant for living humans.
Acrid!
Acrid...
Acrid.
What sound does a C make?
Okay then how do you pronounce acid?
Dummy!
English language is hard.
Oh my god.
Wowee.
They just throw you straight in...
Man, baby.
Okay.
No more time for baby games anymore.
We're in the home stretch, you guys.
This is it.
This is the home stretch.
Can I have some health at least though?
Like for real?
Okay.
Like a blueberry would be so appreciated.
Okay, save the game.
Now that we're here.
Level 9.
31?
Huh?
Wait.
Lampy, thanks for the gift!
What was that?
Can you guys shut up in here?
Okay.
Whoa, this place is crazy looking.
Excuse you.
Oh my god.
I knew it.
Hold on, I'm gonna load.
I'm just gonna restart.
It's okay.
I'll just restart.
In fact, I'm just gonna...
Leave me alone.
Uglies.
Okay, anyway.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Is this a maze or...
Oh my god.
I can see there's like...
They're shooting at me from so, so far away.
Oh, there's the exit.
Humans are not supposed to be here.
I think I made a mistake.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Jump scare.
That's the sound I make too whenever I hear you.
I hear you when I see your ugly face.
I go...
Take that.
That guy wasn't even walking.
He was just literally sliding.
Spring back memories of the Star Wars, Dark Forces game and Jedi Knight games.
Those were classics.
I've never played those.
Well, I wouldn't have played something that's Star Wars.
It's not really my thing.
Did you know that there's actually a Doom game of...
Wait.
Oh, I thought I saw.
There's a Doom game of cereal.
What the hell is in here?
I'm so glad I came in here for the blueberry.
I need a blue key.
Where is it coming from?
The Chex game.
Yes, yes.
I think that's the one.
Are these guys just going to keep respawning?
I need a yellow key.
This is all a little confusing.
But we'll get it.
We'll get there.
Would you play it?
Sure.
Why not?
Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh God.
I think I got him though.
Nice.
Where is he?
Where are you going?
Oh my God.
Oh, I can't believe I dodged that.
Where are you going?
Okay.
Also a Christian Doom game on Noah's Ark.
That sounds awesome.
Save the game real quick.
Matrix dodge there.
That's called being a Touhou player.
That's called playing Touhou.
Oh, one time in your life.
How do I get here?
Hmm.
There's so much stuff going on around here.
Oh, we got the red key.
Nice.
Is this a secret level?
I think so.
Because it says level 31.
But aren't there only like...
Technically...
Sorry.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of this.
Whatever is going on here.
By the way, guys, my meeting is at 1130 if you could just help me.
If you could help me if I stay here too late.
Oh, hello.
No, not that.
Okay.
Anymore?
Anymore.
Time zones though.
Well, right now it's 917 for me.
What's down here?
How long is that?
I think it's a couple of hours.
Who's down there?
Who is that?
A baron of hell.
Sorry.
That's me.
Oh.
I just shot you.
I just sent you to an early grave.
Or maybe it's a properly timed grave.
Who knows?
Okay.
We got the blue, which means we can go get whatever the heck that thing was.
Which was...
Here.
Oh, I keep forgetting that I have...
Right here.
Okay.
What's going on?
Oh no.
What are you?
What is this thing?
Why won't you let me have you?
Also, I cannot get over the fact that like demons in hell have to like... they can't even finish their bridges.
Are they so stupid?
They don't know how to build?
You'll need that.
It powers up the Unmaker.
Okay, we'll have to come back for it.
Wait, where else can I go with the blue?
But I flipped some sort of switch, so maybe...
It's this.
Oh, oh, oh, I didn't realize it was... Okay, no worries.
Oh, here we go!
Oh, too fast.
Just kidding.
This honestly looks like a nether build.
Because of the colors?
I can see it.
What if I go across when it's up?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, never mind.
We never needed it after all.
Okay, what other yellow places could we go?
What better way to spend your birthday than watching your Kamiyoshi playing one of the games that made most of your childhood?
Oh, shoot!
Yellow!
Oh my gosh.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Shu.
Happy birthday!
I feel like it's been a while since I've seen you.
I hope you're doing well.
Unless you've been around, and I'm just blind.
I'm really sorry.
Wait, why don't you come down?
Come down, little hell baby.
Wall button... I already pressed it.
It opened up something else.
See?
It's not the wall button... but maybe another wall button somewhere.
How hard it is to finish your bridges when some Doomguy keeps killing your workforce.
Everyone here.
All the pinkies and all that are being like...
Hey, man, you shouldn't be here.
This place is really dangerous.
It's still under construction.
Hey man, you need to wear a hard hat!
And we're just like, rip a chair!
Screw your safety!
What was this over here?
Oh yeah, how do I get in through here?
Mysterious.
I don't want to just leave yet though.
Unless it's one of those, like, you walk up to it and that's when it comes down.
I'm not sure.
I'm looking for any other wall.
Any other wall buttons.
I don't see any though.
Go towards the exit, not all the way until you get a quake.
Ah!
So it is exactly...
Oops, wrong way.
It is exactly as I thought it was.
Wait, wrong way.
I was the right way.
This way.
Run!
Where did it go?
Did it teleport?
Hide and seek?
Oh, maybe it was in that spot down here.
The grunts are like, hey man, it's dangerous in here.
And Doomguy is just like, yeah, it is, but not for me.
I think I...
You were too slow!
Story of my life.
Doomguy is like...
Actually...
Like a meter tall, okay guys?
It's not his fault.
He is really, really short.
Do I just run off the side?
100% everything.
The spiral.
Where are we at now?
Okay.
Yes.
Are they your Doom or are you their Doom?
Oh, now we're 19.
Really makes you think.
Ew.
Wait, what goes here?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
Wow, there's a whole party in there.
Hope I'm not disrupting anything.
Let's grab this guy first.
Dang.
Who is...
Who is blowing up?
Oh.
I think him.
Your aim.
Aim doko.
Oh.
Dang.
That really would have hit me.
Here we go.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh, there's several of them.
Okay.
This is fine.
This is not fine.
Oh my god.
They're all coming here.
I don't want to be trapped in here.
Yeah.
In fight.
Oh my god.
How did I manage?
How did I live?
I don't know.
I don't know how I lived.
There we go.
Die already.
Oh my god.
The dodge, though.
I do be doing a little bit of game.
Maybe I can get them from down here.
Oh.
Doomguy just infamously doesn't know how to lift up, you know?
Infamously does not know how to lift up a gun.
Oh they're fighting?
The girls are fighting?
Oh.
Okay.
Now I'm fighting the girls.
Shut up.
Wooo!
All righty guys...
Oh guys, oh guys, oh guys o guys o guys o guys o guys o guys o guys o guy  HE DID IT AGAIN
That was really scary.
That was not fun.
Oops, I did it again.
With your heart got lost.
Okay, we can kill this guy though.
But now I know that there's a second one.
Well, there's a couple, but you know.
That guy right there.
Did you notice?
You didn't notice me.
Oh, you didn't.
You noticed me.
Excuse you.
I'm in the middle of something.
Actually,
what if I just unmade it?
Unmaker!
Here we go.
Time to unmake.
How I unmade your mother.
The girls are not fighting.
Though they should be.
I'm going to save the game.
There's a nice blueberry over there.
Whose footprints are these?
Wait, what else was...
Oh, I was grabbing the armor.
That's what I wanted to grab.
Once it comes back down...
I don't want to...
Oh, and there's a backpack there too, even.
Nice.
I'll take everything that you got.
I'm robbing them blind.
Whose footprints are these?
Did I grab this?
Do I need this?
No.
Okay.
Let's go hit the button.
And chain gun it up.
I love the projectile enemies.
They're super fun to dodge.
It feels like...
Like when I'm playing a...
Oh my gosh.
When I'm playing a rhythm game, you know?
Just die already!
Why are there so many of you?
My ears!
My heckin' ears, man.
God,
my ears.
Take it a sippy.
That was crazy.
That was pretty crazy.
I didn't even get to hit the button.
I thought they came out with the button.
I was very mistaken.
But we didn't take as much damage as we could have, so maybe a win.
This is a different area, right?
We need the red key.
I'm just going to save one more time.
Let's go.
Okay, how much ammo do I even have?
541?
Oh, it's not bad at all.
Do I need... did I even use this?
Nope.
Okay.
I'm good.
Alright.
Let's go.
There was nothing in here, right?
Nothing opened up?
Nothing secret?
No?
Okay.
How do I get the blueberry?
How do I get the key?
How do I get everything?
Where am I?
I wish I could look down or up.
Wait, where am I?
Did I get the key?
No.
Wait.
No fall damage.
He didn't
die.
I missed two.
Dang.
I almost had a perfect record.
You guys ruined my streak.
Cool.
So I got the red keys.
Now we can continue onwards.
What?
Wow, what a short, short episode.
I mean, the last one was really, really long, so...
100% breakdown.
That's me.
I'm having a break.
Yeah.
So true.
So true game.
This level?
Uh-oh.
Am I in for it?
There's an old DDR song that goes...
Breakdown.
Ba-da-da-da-ba-da-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-da-ba-ba-da-ba-ba.
It was one of my favorites to play always.
Da-da...
Ah!
What have I just...
Oh, I need a blue key.
Ba-da-da-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Oh my god!
Did that hit me?
Yes, it did.
So sad.
No, no, no.
You.
Oops.
Be for you.
Oh gosh, you guys remember it too?
We're so old.
We're so old, you guys.
Oh, we can just kind of go up here and...
Take them down.
Two by two.
One by one is for babies.
Two by two, baby.
Why won't you die?
I'm not old.
Breaks back.
Why is the music so frightening?
How do I get down from here?
There we go.
Picked up a clip.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
I'll take it all.
Oh, that's not a blueberry at all.
Um, how.
Now.
Brown.
Cow.
I'm showing too much skin to the viewers?
How embarrassing.
No.
I'm just showing...
Should I just cover my face?
I don't see anything to, like, push.
Except the thing that's all the way up there.
Too much exposed.
No.
Do you guys see any buttons or...
Do you guys...
Have you guys seen one?
The walls are made of flesh.
No.
Maybe the floor is made of flesh.
Shoot from afar, maybe.
Let's try it.
This is actually spooky.
Oh, from the upper level.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not going to make it.
Oh my God.
There we go.
Whew.
Thanks, guys, for watching.
Thanks for your help.
Much appreciated.
Push, push.
Oh!
Are
these bars?
She's spitting.
I thought they were going to have dummy demons inside.
Ooh, we're going down...
I'm sorry for disturbing!
Starving!
Where are you?
Nice butt!
Very cool.
You're not sorry.
Come on!
What's in the other one though?
I saw two doors open.
Wait.
Secret!
So many secrets around here.
Oh, never mind.
I thought both of them opened.
Just the one did.
Okay, cool.
Let's keep going.
Sorry for disturbing you.
Shoots rocket at your face?
It's not...
It's nothing personal.
It's just...
It's nothing personal, kid.
It's just business.
It's just business, everybody.
Wait, where am I?
I don't remember this...
This maze.
What's going to happen when I open...?
Wait, this way?
Oh my goodness!
Maze of men.
Only the strongest, Mei.
Yellow key.
A maze made for only real men.
Uh-oh.
What's going to happen in here?
No!
Cool walls.
They're pretty cool.
Where are we at?
20?
Yeah.
Each level now has multiple save.
Oh, no.
I
don't know why I'm using up this bolt... these bullets.
I'm an idiot.
There we go.
Ah!
There is a key down there.
Come on.
There we go.
Give me...
Let me have the bullets, please.
Okay.
You think it's safe?
I don't know.
Do you think it's...
Oh my
god.
They're so obsessed with me.
Oh, no.
Their bodies disappeared.
I thought it was so cool.
There was like a whole thing of pinkies.
Wow.
That's a lot of health.
That's pretty generous.
Nice.
Okay.
Is there anything?
Uh...
Red key?
I'm hearing something, but like not the ombi...
on some hearing...
Like I think I heard like a vroom.
Which way do I go?
Where am I?
Oh!
Okay.
This is the secret room, and then this goes...
This is the door.
I
don't understand.
I'm like, what should I do?
There is a recording right there.
Okay.
This is where we just came from.
How do I leave?
Tummy hort.
That was you, your tummy...
Oh!
Nevermind, we don't need to leave.
We've got this.
That's the neat part, you don't.
I'm figuring that out real fast.
Wow.
Hell is so great this time of year.
Oh my gosh!
Don't shoot me!
Just gonna...
Oh dang.
I can't lift my tiny arms up high enough.
Oh my god!
I got three in one!
That's kind of cool.
It's kind of exciting.
Triple.
I don't think I've ever had a triple kill before.
Do you think hell is more bearable than the current earth weather?
Summer just started and it's already 105.
Wait.
Is it officially summer now?
Gosh, there's a lot of these.
A lot of like little...
Oh, there he is!
As of last Friday!
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there's two of them.
Oh...
No, no, I got stuck on the door.
Nice.
Not nice.
I mean, I still got stuck on the door but...
Wow, how did that happen?
Happy summer!
I didn't realize that it happened already.
I feel really silly now.
I even have a... I have a podcast based off of it being summer.
I didn't even realize it was summer.
Silly me.
I think Matara talked about it on her stream, so I'll mention it too.
What the...
Oh my gosh.
You bastards.
Did you shoot each other?
I think they shot each other.
But basically...
Because our Japan trip kind of like went haywire...
We were trying to figure out when we can go...
Go back.
To do the stuff that we wanted to do.
We basically decided in August, so...
Wait, what moved?
Something over there.
Something over here.
Here?
Huh?
Am I missing it?
Enjoy the weather.
Well, I mean we would have gone in July, so it would have been awful anyway.
Imagine being on summer.
LMAO, this super was sponsored by Southern Hemisphere Gang.
Yippee!
But yeah, it's just kind of what we got to do.
Basically.
Maybe this is what opens up.
But no, it's not.
Huh.
What's happening on my...
Yeah, it's happening...
I have no idea.
Plasma gun!
Okay, we at least got that.
Oh.
Wait, this is where we came from.
Okay, nevermind.
Oh, wait.
We're already here.
Where the hell am I?
That's me...
That's me when I think about going to Japan in summer.
Ahaha.
Waow, waow.
Waow.
Ou.
For some reason, I thought that this would...
That that was going to be the thing that would open.
Once I press all the switches.
I'm no friend.
I'm so lost.
This looks like it could open.
Where am I?
Do you plan on playing the custom Doom 2 level MyHouse.Wad?
People have asked about it.
Oh!
I am not going to say no.
Oh my gosh.
Because I don't really have a reason to say no.
I just don't have any plans to play it right now.
Like to give a definitive like...
Oh yeah, I'm going to play it next week kind of deal, you know.
Run.
Run from the lost soul.
Please!
Just come up here!
My favorite enemy.
Absolutely.
Hmm.
How do we get to there?
Curious.
Oh, interesting.
Hmm.
How do we get there?
To get the sphere?
Trying to save up to visit Japan.
What should I book first?
My flight or a hotel?
I would say book your flight first.
But also, a lot of...
I mean, you could always book your hotel first.
But flights are going to be the most expensive thing.
So...
And they fluctuate so much.
Hotel prices aren't going to fluctuate so much.
So it's kind of like...
You know, if you were to...
If you were to get it and like...
If you were to get to your hotel but those specific dates are super duper expensive.
It would really suck.
You know?
I do not know hotel prices.
No, no, no.
I meant the flight prices will fluctuate.
Not the hotel.
The hotel prices are pretty...
Yeah.
Now that...
Now hoping that somebody makes a mint mugshot mod for Doom.
Yeah.
But...
Hmm.
How do you get to that door?
Okay.
Now...
We hit the thing.
Oh.
We have the yellow key.
That's right.
The yellow key was...
Right.
This is secret room.
This is room...
To...
Where you need...
The yellow key.
Right.
No.
Okay.
Let's try to get over to the exit.
Hold on.
We'll figure it out.
Yeah.
See?
I knew it.
I told you guys.
What's this?
Oh gosh.
The exit!
The exit?
Is this my Doom or is this the exit?
Your game plan?
Gameplay makes me want to play DOOM now.
I don't know if that's a good way or a bad way.
Okay!
No sphere.
Too bad.
Only 31% of the items.
That's crazy.
Wait, we got more secrets than we got the items.
What time is it?
10.
Okay, I have an hour and a half.
Oh, yikes.
Ouch!
Why do these guys never miss?
Red.
I gotta pick up the pace.
Oh, save?
Yes, thank you.
We're at level 21!
Nice.
Oh, yellow key.
Oh, wowee!
Good job.
I heard them.
I heard them to my left and to my right.
Oh my gosh.
Where are they?
They're like down... Oh, wait.
They're somewhere.
Oh, they're everywhere.
Oh my god!
They're everywhere!
Don't fall.
Oh, that wasn't very nice of them.
Wipe his ass.
I'm... I'm trying.
I love sniping with the shotgun.
This area is really... I don't like it because it's kind of confusing me.
Can I... Like, I can't tell.
Can I drop down or what?
And I hear more guys.
Like, over in here.
Is this where you're at?
Oh!
Oh my god!
There's a big guy in here.
And there's more over there.
The ground is lava.
How do I get in there?
Hmm.
Guess someday.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I'm alive.
You know what?
Since we have this though...
Go around.
Find everything.
There's another portal.
Oh, there's not much...
Never mind.
There's...
Wait.
Over here.
There's an arrow.
There's not much going on in here.
Green.
Woo!
Secret.
I can't hit him.
I don't think.
Uh... Here?
Oh, they all lead to the same spot.
Green.
Mental vision.
Oh.
Good thing I was far, far away from that wall.
There we go.
Got him, boys.
But how... I can't...
Okay, so running across that is kind of useless.
Maybe something in here.
Who turned off the green?
Thank goodness they turned off the green.
My eyes.
This is what it's like living with ectoplasm.
Green.
Button.
I don't understand this level...
design at all.
I think.
I think I'm really confused.
Wait.
That's where we came from.
Are you enjoying the game so far?
It's so much fun!
And both teleporters took me to the same place?
This one is pretty complicated.
Okay.
Hmm.
Is it this area or...
Okay.
This is probably a dumb idea.
Is it here?
Ah!
Wait, no!
This is just a hole!
It is a place!
Just not the correct place!
Wait, up there even?
Oh no, it's just fire.
Just a hole.
Maybe I should run over...
Okay, I'm gonna try.
Yeah!
Oh!
I did it.
Dang, I thought I could snipe that guy from...
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just wanted to get rid of him.
In any way possible.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Okay.
Cool.
Oh!
Whoa!
Wait.
Okay.
Yeah...
Double kill.
I'm the doomed eye.
What's the point of going up here?
There is nothing here!
Right?
I'm not just blind, am I?
There's nothing here.
Okay.
Keep looking?
Oh, I have to go the other way.
Lampy!
Thanks for another gift.
Thank you!
Keep looking.
The music is making me feel clownish.
I'm looking to see if there's anything I can shoot?
I don't see anything though!
I don't see anything.
I think I've gone bonkers.
I'll take that!
But nothing!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Free!
Free blueberry!
No strings attached!
Let's go!
Free blueberry!
No strings attached!
I think there's what?
24 levels or something in this game?
24 or 25?
I don't remember what you guys told me.
We're on 21.
It could be that because these levels get way more complicated, I won't be able to finish today.
But...
I'm gonna do my darndest.
You said nothing here and it echoed in my mind as by a phantasmal Russian.
I do it all the time!
Nothing here.
I'm...
Maybe I just run.
Wait, no, there's...
Do I...
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
This area is nice and all, but there's nothing here.
Oh, here we go.
Oh!
Wait, hold on a second.
Okay, never mind.
I figured it out.
All on my own.
Using my brain and my brain alone.
25 normal levels.
Oh, I thought it was 24.
Also...
Wait.
I need a red...
I don't know actually.
Oh my gosh.
This is the worst place to be stuck with you.
It's so narrow.
As expected of Minto.
That looks like a door.
Okay.
Oh, this looks like a door.
Actual jail.
Real jail.
Idiot.
Box of rockets.
Did it open up now?
No.
Horny jail.
Oh my god.
I sure hope not.
Oh, there we go.
I don't want him thinking of me.
Wait.
So things are opening up and it's...
Oh gosh, this map, man.
This is where we just came from.
Yeah.
And then we went this way.
And we can go...
Oh, wait.
This looks like an awfully bad idea.
I don't think I can go there.
What is that?
Oh, I got an area map.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
No, wait.
I don't think I want that.
Uh oh.
Wait a second.
I don't think I want an area map because I want to know where I have not been before.
I don't know if I am a fan of that.
Oh my gosh, stop roaring in my ear!
I don't like this RP anymore!
Stop roaring in my ear!
Nice.
Oh, it opened!
Here!
Okay.
Ew!
What?
What was that?
Did it open in here?
No, I think down here.
Oh my god!
Oh, that was really bad.
That was really bad.
Yikes!
I thought... Whoa!
Whoa!
That's quite the room for the blue key!
We're just gonna do that.
There we go!
I don't think there's anything... yeah.
Okay.
I don't trust.
I have no trust.
I do not trust.
Ouch!
I might just reset.
What am I?
I'm... I'm hard of seeing.
That's what I am.
How do I grab you?
Wait, I can't see anything.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna reload.
Sorry, guys.
Oh, that's the invincible!
I'm bulletproof!
Nothing to lose!
Fire away!
Ricochet!
You take your aim!
Fire away!
You shoot me down!
But I won't fall!
I am titanium!
You shoot me down!
But I won't fall!
I am titanium!
Bow-wow-wow-wow-wow.
Bow-wow-wow-wow-wow-wow.
Oof.
I said I wasn't gonna do many karaoke.
Because I'm trying to, like, rest my voice.
Oh, I don't need those either.
Trying to rest my voice for, like, the concert and stuff.
Um...
But...
I just felt like doing it this week because I don't...
I'm not feeling so well.
And doing karaoke cheers me up even if it's just silly music.
Silly songs.
Wait, there's a concert?
Yeah!
I have a concert!
During Anime Expo.
Virtual vacation!
It's not at Anime Expo, but it's during the weekend.
Yes!
Resave.
Okay, cool.
Where was...
Oh my god, that scared me.
Synapse, thank you!
Oh my god.
I thought I heard, like, whispering.
It freaked me out.
It was my own voice.
Thank you so much.
I was like...
Oh, here it is.
Another one?
You are so unoriginal.
I like the... I like your...
I like the guy outside the door better.
Oh...
I don't know what else to expect.
Where do I go?
Wait, is this new?
Is this new?
Oh, this is where I came from, isn't it?
Save?
Yeah, you're right.
You're so right.
Okay.
It opened something somewhere.
Somewhere...
Maybe in here?
No, that has not opened yet.
Okay.
But we're keeping that in the back of our brains.
I think I'm going too far away.
Haha.
Horny jail unchanged.
Oh, this map.
Sounds like people...
Maybe this is a bit of an infamous map.
Due to how...
Complicated it is.
In here.
No.
Quite changed.
I don't think any...
I don't see anything over there.
Wait, here?
No, I just made a circle.
What changed?
Oh my goodness.
I'm as zoomed out as I can be.
I hope there's nothing alive around here.
Maybe down here.
No.
Hahaha.
Blue door?
That's where...
That's where we just came from though.
And we...
Flipped the switch that is now gone.
And something opened up.
Yeah, we're still missing a red key.
Um...
Unless we go back to the main area but...
I don't know.
Maybe...
Haha.
Huh?
Hahaha.
Oh, that's a lamp.
Ah, maybe we go back to the main area.
Oh.
Did this lift up?
No.
Ehhhh.
Ehhh.
Hahaha.
I am now...
Oh, there's the red key over there.
There, you can see it.
You need to go back to the main area for the red key.
Yeah, I'm here.
Oh, wait.
Oh, maybe I lifted up this part.
Never mind.
Don't tell me anything.
I cracked my statement.
Also, armor.
I did see it.
I did see the armor.
Okay.
Nice!
Nice, nice.
I don't know.
I think if I get the armor...
I do need it though, don't I?
I do need it.
Wait, we can try again.
We can try again.
I think.
I do need it though.
Nice!
Lost a little bit of health, but maybe it was worth it.
Okay, now we go back...
Oh, to that one room.
Oh my gosh, I keep going the wrong way.
We go back to the one door that had the yellow and the red, right?
I believe.
Phew!
Speed run!
It was right here.
What?
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
Maybe I shoot this.
Ah ha!
Wow!
Ah!
You jerk.
Maybe... this was nothing all along.
Thank you.
Sorry,
I swallowed my spit wrong.
Um...
Oh, I picked up a clip.
Were there any other red areas?
Yeah, I already have a plasma gun.
No worries.
Besides there, were there any other red doors?
Ugh.
Look at all these squirming, squishy...
I'm not so sure, guys.
I'm not so sure.
Where'd it go?
This says nothing in here.
Nothing here.
Did you hear about the redneck couple that found the blind newborn deer?
Scientists came to see if it was a new species.
Said if they named it, they could keep it.
The wife said, that's a bad eye-deer.
Eye-deer...
Um...
I took so...
I took damage from that one.
I think I took da- wait, what's in there?
I think I took damage from that one.
I love and hate it.
That's a... that's a bad eye-deer.
I get it.
Yeah, see, there seems to be stuff inside.
Guys, I'm not so sure.
I'm not so sure.
I know where to go, what to do.
We got the red key.
I know that there was a...
I wonder if the door... actually, hold on, let's check the door.
Because there was a... there was a...
Door at the very, very beginning, wasn't there?
I think.
But we've been locked out.
Yes, it's open.
Here, here.
Wait, is this the exit?
The game is not so kind.
Well, maybe that opened it.
Maybe.
Okay.
I thought that was gonna be the exit, which is why I hadn't gone back to it, but...
Aha!
Oh!
Of course you're here.
Of course you're here to ruin my day, to ruin my time, to ruin my moment.
You're just here to be like...
Oh, this is all about me.
It's not all about you, Mr. Baron.
It's not all about you.
Into the void!
Minty sweat!
Welcome back.
Not that many secrets.
Burnt offerings.
Oh, the sky is literally just on fire now.
Oh!
That's really exciting.
I think
I'm hitting it.
Oh, yes I am.
Take that, spitter.
Oh, I thought that was a web or a bad guy.
Okay.
All right.
Run.
Oh, my God!
Oh, please!
Please!
I think I...
Wait!
Hold on!
I accidentally hit Caps Lock!
Guys, I accidentally hit Caps Lock, which in turn turned off my running for a brief moment.
Save.
Oh, gosh.
I should have done that way before.
Shouldn't I?
Oopsie!
I should have done that before.
It's fine.
Maybe.
Okay.
Hold on.
Look at the sky.
Gosh!
Hell is...
Oh my God.
Oh my god.
So wonderful this time of year!
Oh, I think I got these guys... or at least I got one of them before.
So I completely forgot about it.
Why are you leaping at me?
You freak!
Could have been better.
Could have been worse.
Excuse you.
Trying to find all these things around here.
Oh my god, the chainsaw!
And berserk.
Come here little pickle!
Pinky pickle!
A chainsaw, what?
A mother trucking chainsaw, what?
So come and get it.
What does the orb do?
What does the pearl do?
Mega health and armor!
Oh boy!
200!
Wait, I thought it was...
What's in here?
Okay, hold on.
Get ready.
Oh.
I can't reach it.
I was like, okay, here I go!
I like bread and butter pickles.
Like...
What does that entail?
A bread and butter pickle.
Like, I've heard of butter pickles before.
Give me a key or something!
I don't want your ugly ass!
Oh, there's a key up there.
What the...
You thought you were sneaky, huh?
Is that a...
Yes.
A meatball!
It's a meatball!
You know you've played...
You know you've played too much when you actually can start recognizing like the different...
The different noises.
You're like, that's the sound of a...
Of a meatball!
Call that fire.
Look at it.
Yes.
Oh my gosh, what a lovely view from the balcony.
My nose is soft.
Don't listen to that, actually.
There we go.
Taking in all that...
Smoke.
Carbon dioxide.
Very Guy Fieri.
True, true, true, true.
He would love this place.
Do you think he's the devil?
Wait, where...
How do I get the blue key?
It's up there.
From the window, maybe?
Condiments are...
Oh, wait.
No!
Wait, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
I got it.
I hope there wasn't anything else up there, actually.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
Let's do it one more time.
One more time.
Six minutes before 1130?
No, no.
I have one more hour.
One more hour.
But thank you for...
Thank you for being...
For...
For checking.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, nice.
Not anymore.
Anyone else want to attack?
Test me!
Hmm...
Aaaaaa!
Aaa!
Aaaah!
Aaaaaaaah!
ler
is my free blueberry after that?
Where?
I deserve a blueberry after that.
After that...
I don't know.
I deserve a blueberry after that.
I almost died!
You failed the test!
But how else was I supposed to open the door?
How else was the door supposed to open?
The pearl is nearby but I can't...
My legs are too short.
There was a secret room.
There was?
I'll be back for you.
Wow!
That's so awesome!
Thank you for the birthday!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
You've been a huge inspiration to me.
I've been working extra hard at getting wax and honey this year in hopes of eventually having something to show off to my Oshii.
What are you talking about?
I already think it's so cool that you do the whole bee thing in general.
That guy...
Wait a second.
I was gonna say, this guy looks a little different.
He looks...
This guy looks really funky.
What are you hiding here?
What are you hiding?
I think I have to go up to the other...
I have to go back up there.
Hold on.
Oh, there is health here.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
You!
Blueberry!
What?
Wow!
That...
That guy was...
I was gonna say he looks...
Can I come up?
He looked a little different.
Now I'm getting greedy.
Everybody must have a blueberry body.
There's also this over here.
This is all water, so I'm assuming if we fall...
It'll be okay.
We have a blue key.
Where was the blue door?
Over...
Yon?
When did this open?
Is that a spider over there?
Just gonna...
Um...
Phew.
That was close.
That was a close one.
Anyone else in here?
I'm not gonna ask anybody if they wanna test me ever again because...
I learned my lesson.
Coco the demon!
Yeah.
Minto ball!
No!
We're ball...
Oh my gosh, I saw...
Did you guys...
Do you guys know the Yeti?
They um...
They make t-shirts and stuff like that.
And I saw that they put one out today.
That was just Garfield.
And it says...
Sometimes I'm ballin' and it shows Garfield playing b-ball.
And then it says...
Or sometimes I'm ballin'.
And it just shows him crying.
I was like, Garfield...
No, Garf!
Garf!
Okay, yellow key means...
Yellow door was...
Oh, over there!
I'm going to get the Miku Garfield figure.
Isn't that a U2's though?
I'm not...
I'm not really a fan.
The U2's are...
Oh my god!
Wait, no!
Don't kill me!
I don't wanna die!
There was a blueberry right there!
Every time...
Not every time.
Don't be dramatic.
What?!
Someone's snoring up a storm in there.
Oh, I think it was him.
Oh, just kidding.
There's more sleepy, lazy guys.
See?
Blueberry...
All good.
Mint slayer.
Hater of wisps.
Protector of Oshis.
Slay the demons.
I'm not a hater of wisps.
No...
Look at these losers in jail.
What
is this?
What is this?
What's gonna happen in here?
It's a tarp!
Is every single one gonna open up?
Or...
That's a lot of rockets!
This is actually...
Kinda cool.
Oh, I need to...
Okay, fine!
I'll open the door!
They were like...
Why are you standing inside there, little baby?
What are you standing inside there for, little baby?
Little baby...
What does that do?
Oops, wrong one.
Oh, I gotta open the door.
Little baby...
Don't just stand inside here.
Nice.
Okay!
Red key acquired!
You...
Again?
I'm afraid of blowing up on myself.
There we go.
Okay.
Anyone else?
Gonna come out?
Wait, what is this over here then?
I don't think we're done, you guys.
I don't think we're quite so done.
Ow!
Wait!
What is the exit?
Oh my god!
Ouch!
Huh.
But the exit...
Wow, this room is really pretty.
Can you climb the little ledge around the water?
Oh, yeah.
I see it.
It would be you.
Oh!
Ouch!
What just opened?
Come on.
Come on, Doomguy.
This is why you have tiny legs.
Be careful, Minto.
Do you think...
Do you think it was the orb?
No.
How do I get you?
Unless it's a timed thing.
What do you guys think?
Do you think it's timed?
Okay, let's try it again.
Hidden door by the blue door.
Oh, wait!
This also went up!
It just gave me a...
It's just a gun that I don't need.
Hidden door by the blue door.
Blue door.
Blue door?
Here.
Secret.
Hey!
Burnt offerings.
Secrets?
Unholy temple!
Okay, hold on.
Let me save the game before we do anything else.
Yes.
It's okay.
Goodbye, secret level.
23!
We have three more levels, I think, right?
She listens to our back seating.
Yeah, because I trust you guys!
Thank you for the help.
Thank you!
Yeah, the fire is green now.
You're right.
Um...
No, yeah.
You're not gonna come down here.
You little baby.
I like the snarl that, uh...
That pinkies make.
You think I can hit him?
Wah!
Nope.
I hear another one.
I know, probably.
It might be overkill, but...
I just...
I just feel safer.
Oh.
Oh!
Shoot!
I didn't think it would reach me!
Because most of them hit the walls.
Ripperonium.
It just got the orb.
Oh.
I'm sniping with my shotgun!
Sometimes they can hit me, and sometimes I can't!
Idiot!
Get shotgun sniped!
Oh, we need all three for this door.
Okay.
How do I get up there, anyway?
I hear a spider in there.
Uh, not here.
Ta-ta-ta-ta-ta-ta.
I'd like to take them out if I could.
Because I'd like to not go up there and have to deal with them.
I'd like to not go up there and have to deal with them.
Sniping with shotguns.
Yeah, you know.
All the best gamers do it.
It's like totally in normal, natural.
It's the new meta, everybody.
You know meta.
There we go.
Meta is everything, right?
Meta over...
Waifu.
Wait, what?
What just happened?
Wait, what just actually...
Wait, huh?
These things up there, maybe?
Oh my god.
They're like homing.
Can you take the armor, please?
They were like homing missiles though.
How do I get up?
Does this...
Open up, please.
Wall missiles.
Oh, oh my god.
That's where they are.
At least I got one.
There we go.
Two.
What just opened up?
I heard a sound.
No, those aren't cyber demons.
They were just the...
The barons, right?
Oh my god.
Stop.
Don't do this to me.
Please.
Oh.
Never mind.
Not like this.
So rude.
Oh, here we go.
Something opened up.
I'm going around.
Checking everything.
Checking what's going on.
I can't.
Oh wait.
How do I get out of here?
It's not timed.
I hope.
Wait, here we go.
Holy.
Is Mint winning?
I think.
So, maybe.
I don't know.
Probably.
I think so.
See, it doesn't happen every time.
Yeah.
Face on my feet.
Arrrrr.
Huh.
Ah.
Hehehe.
What?
Why are you falling?
Where are the piggies falling from the sky?
Ah.
No!
This is getting ridiculous!
I took less damage than I expected to.
Am I gaming?
Am
I gaming?
Minto Gaming.
Open up, please.
I did your stupid task.
Give me the key.
I did your task.
Please.
Please give me the key.
I did what you asked of me.
Please.
Open up, please.
Oh, here it is.
I'll be back for you.
I guess.
What?
I can't shoot him, but this guy can shoot me?
Wait.
No, no, no, I don't...
I don't trust it.
Where was he, anyway?
Okay, so we got the blue key.
Which...
was...
very...
much of a place that I remember.
Actually, it doesn't even show on the map.
It doesn't show on...
I don't remember seeing a blue door.
Oh.
Okay.
Good.
Me neither.
Stop shooting at me.
I can't get through.
I don't have a yellow or a red.
I think the game put us in the wrong order.
Let me...
Ah!
Oh, come on.
This is so cheap.
Okay.
Red!
Let's go!
I was gonna say, have they had enough time to replenish the...
the bombs, but clearly they have.
I'm gonna save again.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
Let's go.
Whoa.
There's a lot of guys in here.
I think I'm glad I'm saved.
I think I'm glad I saved.
Where was the other guy?
There was just another random dude in here.
Where'd he go?
I hope I killed...
Oh, my God.
These guys.
Please.
I will actually die.
Oh, my God.
There's another one going to pop up!
There's another one going to pop up, please say no.
I was prepared this time.
Oh, come on.
Wait, exit.
Oh, I have a hundred, my bad.
Rude game!
We're safe right now.
Rude, rude, rude, rude, rude.
I love that the PNGs in this game all turn towards you.
Because I know it's probably like, you know...
It's so that they never appear flat.
But it also just makes it so much spookier.
Super rude.
So, so rude.
Good thing I saved beforehand, I suppose.
Okay, what is this?
Okay, let's go grab this.
And... cool.
So now we have all...
Wait, we have all three.
I just realized.
Never mind.
Chat's filled with excitement as they react to a player named MintoGaming.
They use phrases like, Yes, you are Minto and true gamer if I ever saw one.
Yippee!
Okay.
Let's keep going then.
Yes!
You...
Are Minto.
Wait, why is this closed back up?
This is so rude.
There's still health in here.
Okay.
Just gonna blast him.
Oh, I don't think that actually worked.
I don't think that actually...
I don't think I actually aimed for him at all.
There we go.
Took care of his meaty ass.
I'm gonna go get it also.
There's so...
Ah!
No!
Hey!
This game is so rude.
This game is so unbearably rude.
Come on!
I have all three!
What do I...
What am I hearing?
I don't actually remember how I got up here.
To be honest.
I don't quite remember.
Oh!
Take this.
Ah!
Oh!
The portal!
Yes!
Thank you!
It was all the way on the other side, wasn't it?
Wait, no.
On this side.
Yes, there was a teleporter.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for the reminder.
Thank you.
This one.
Okay.
Run!
Please, God, no!
Oh, no!
Why did I come in...
Why did I come back in here?
I'm such an idiot.
Of all places I could have picked for protection.
What's wrong with me?
Go, go, go, go!
Oh, it's open again.
Oh!
I didn't realize this was a...
We're okay.
I'll come back for you, my precious.
Um...
I came back for you!
Oh!
What?!
Oh my...
Ahh!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh!
Okay.
Phew.
Okay, we're good.
I'm coming back for you.
I'm coming back for you!
No.
I did it.
Wait.
How do I open these now?
It said, don't leave me, darling.
I know.
I really did.
Carly Raimi.
I'm coming back for you.
I don't know...
Okay, so we have all the keys, but all the doors that require the three keys are not opening.
Is that at 11 or 11.30?
11.30.
Guys, I don't think we're finishing.
I'm so sad.
No!
I wanted to finish!
Maybe if my meeting isn't so long...
I can continue... afterwards.
After it's done.
Even though it'll be quite late.
Oh, save.
Thank you.
Thank you for the reminder.
I don't... wait, okay.
Late night mint.
Late night minto.
Oh, that's that in there?
Um...
So we pushed those three.
So what else?
Maybe the one inside here.
No.
There was another one.
Uh...
Oh my god, I completely forgot!
And this one's probably also gonna go off too!
The key buttons are in a sequence.
Oh... wait.
Go back to the room where you fought all the pinkies.
Okay.
But I... I know I went back in there though.
And it wasn't open.
In here?
This one?
Have you tried knocking politely?
Pink, pink, pink!
Open up, please!
Oh, wait a second!
Wait a second!
Red, blue, yellow...
Hold on, I'm cooking.
What was the other one?
Um...
The one in here.
Red, blue, yellow...
Are they timed?
I should open...
Oh!
Ah!
Blue, yellow, red!
Blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow, red.
Red, blue, yellow.
Ah-ha!
Ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ah...
Oh!
Blue...
Yellow...
Red!
Oh, shoot.
Guys, which one was that?
Not red?
Shoot.
This way.
Oof!
This one.
The one over there.
Yes!
Ta-da!
Okay.
Then...
Red, blue, yellow was the next one.
And then there was the one all the way downstairs.
I do remember the one in the water.
Oh.
Red, blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow, red, blue, yellow.
Red.
Blue.
Yellow.
Nice.
Okay.
Thank you.
Someone gave me a hint.
They were like, there's a sequence.
So, it wasn't my big brain all by myself.
So, thank you for the hint.
And then, we gotta go see what the last one is.
It's somewhere...
It's over here, I believe.
Okay.
Just, uh...
Just kidding.
It's here.
Oh!
I already unlocked it, because I'm stupid.
Yippee!
What's he doin' up there?
I'm a secret genius!
Hi!
Hello!
I'm a secret genius!
What else is coming down?
What's coming down?
Did the floor turn to lava?
Beep beep!
My phone is going off.
It's like, your meeting is in 30 minutes.
I know!
Oh gosh, okay.
Oh, come on!
What?
Maybe it wasn't the best idea staying up there.
Maybe it wasn't the best idea.
Okay!
That should be the third one!
And then...
Something amazing will happen!
Something...
Really cool!
Wait, where am I?
Oh, okay.
Thanks, I guess, for that.
Something...
Oh!
The exit!
The room that said exit!
This way!
No surprises!
Beep!
Yippee!
No escape!
Save game.
Gosh, we're so close, you guys!
Oh, we're so close!
I wish I could postpone my meeting, for real.
I wish I could be like, um, can you give me like...
A little extra time to beat the game?
Could you just...
How much for a checky with a cute maid?
Stop it!
Could you just give me a little extra time to beat the game?
Oh, wait.
There's a lot going on here.
You're shooting each other!
You're shooting your friend!
Oh.
I thought I could climb on top of that.
What's going on here?
Is that a cyber demon?
What is that sound?
Oh.
Oh my goodness!
Sounds...
Can't even tell if I'm getting him or not.
Oh my god, these are so funny!
Touhou!
Touhou Project!
Wait, people said there were only 25 levels.
Which is it?
I'm so confused.
If you're counting secret levels, then... oh my gosh.
If you're counting secret levels, I'm not gonna do secret levels.
It's okay.
They added more levels with the re-release?
Oh my god.
Okay then.
Maybe it will be another day.
Come on!
Where are you?
Oh, I see him.
Cyber demon.
Okay.
Let's see.
There's a lot going on.
Just kidding.
Wait, this is where I came from.
Okay.
Well, if we ever need health, we know where to get some.
Chat's a bit lost in the... I'm lost in the sauce.
I don't know what's going on at all.
Wait, a box of what?
Oh no!
Wait!
Is this like that one puzzle where you get the special thing?
Okay, I'm not gonna press anymore.
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Can I go any...
I don't think I can.
It's just really sad.
Watching his corpse rise and fall.
Okay, let's see.
Cyber demon?
I think I gotta go down here.
Whoa!
Oh, nice.
Womp womp.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Lost levels are unlocked after beating the original campaign.
They came with a 2020 release.
I see, I see.
There's 25 story levels.
Little 25, 26, 27.
Or fun levels that can be accessed with passwords.
Mmm.
Oh, we don't need that.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and go from here, maybe?
Wait!
Uh oh.
How did I get...
Why is the sky black... back to...
Back to...
Um, red?
I really enjoyed our green flame scenery.
Before.
Yeah, I'm just confused.
I think, yeah, I'll just keep playing until the game is over.
I guess.
Rip and tear until it is done, you know?
That's what the...
Isn't that what are they all the greatest...
Um...
All the greatest, uh...
Doom guys say and everything, you know?
Rip and tear part of your schedule.
I'm really kind of...
Not sure when I'll be able to play it, though.
Um...
Oh.
Nice.
Wait a second.
Are there any other things that look like that?
Oh yeah, there are.
Oh.
Well, I'll take all the rockets.
That's what I will do.
All the greatest Doomers are saying that nowadays.
I just got this armor!
Don't break it.
Okay.
Where even is that?
I have no idea.
Um...
What rockets did I waste?
Uh...
Did I go in this one?
They're always saying it.
If I decide to do one.
Yeah, if I decide, uh...
I might, you know, I might just be too tired.
Cause I'll be...
Oh wait, this is the one I went into before.
I might just be too tired.
Cause...
I'll be endurancing tomorrow as well.
Okay, this is the way we need to go.
This is the way that just opened up.
Gosh, I'm so sorry.
I hate them so much.
I don't...
I don't really want to be screaming at like 2 in the morning.
But you know.
You know how it is.
Don't be a lie.
Don't be a...
Don't be a trap.
There we go.
It's not always a trap.
There's been one time it wasn't a trap.
And I'm...
I'm gonna hold on to that one chance.
Okay, there's definitely something I need to do in here.
I just...
I'm worried that it's gonna be like that...
Thing where I missed out on the cool weapon.
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
You can go up.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, save?
Yeah, that's a good idea.
That's a good idea.
Okay.
Please.
I'm...
I would like for you to go up.
Oh.
Oh god.
I thought I was...
I thought I was trapped.
Wait,
the same one keeps dropping down.
Wait, the same one keeps dropping down.
Is there like an order to it?
Secret ending.
You're just trapped.
I'm so glad that they thought that people might do that.
And decided that if you interact with it, you can get away from it.
Yeah, all the switches do the same thing.
What else is there?
I can't...
I can't get up here, so...
Oh wait, maybe I can shoot it.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Try the elevator, anybody?
Yep, that's exactly what Emery's about to do.
Oh...
I wonder if I can get him a little bit.
I don't think so.
Well that didn't do much...
Yeah, I wanna get the Cyber Demon.
But he's like way... in there.
Sniping with the eye maker?
That's such a good idea.
It's so thin, right?
Come here.
I keep missing my chance.
Come here!
How big is this hitbox?
I don't think it's working.
Maybe I get closer.
Oh, there we go!
I think.
I'm not seeing any blood.
I might just be wasting ammo.
I don't think it's working, you guys.
I don't think it's working!
It doesn't show damage?
Just keep shooting?
Okay.
Oh, that one definitely hit.
That one definitely hit.
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh my god, I did the real hacks.
I feel like a speed run... I mean, I didn't speed run it at all, but...
Oh...
What is that?
Wait, this is the same thing that I'm holding.
Oh my goodness.
They're like, hey, are you ready for this?
I don't think you are.
Wait, I'm at level 28!
Huh?
I'm at level 28.
Just grab everything.
BFG!
Um...
I'm scared.
I'm a bit frightened.
It's... it's quiet.
Oh!
Oh my god, what is this?
Oh my god, it's these... it's these damn... fossils, I swear!
Huh...
I think I can just rock it from here.
Oh, shoot.
Where did that guy come from?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
It's like a floating fetus!
What is this thing?
BFG the crowd?
Oh, okay.
But it's so slow!
The BFG is so slow!
Please use the BFG.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll use the BFG.
I'll use the B...
Oh, wait, let me just load the game.
What am I doing?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll use the BFG.
Which one number is that?
Is this the BFG?
Yeah.
But it's so slow!
I'm nervous.
Well, I guess I'm gonna re-save.
Because once we come...
Once we get out everything, there's no coming back.
So...
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, backpack.
Sorry.
Hold on.
And then...
Wait.
Save?
Yes.
Yeah.
Grab the invincibility.
Here we go!
Come on!
Hurry up, you guys!
I
don't think the BFG was really it, you guys.
Oh, shoot.
I'm just...
I don't think that...
I don't think that was...
I don't think that was it...
I don't think...
BFG is close range.
Okay.
Understandable.
I don't use it very often.
So...
Oh!
Run!
I think.
I think I'm so doomed.
Oh, there's a backside to this?
Hold on.
Are you guys sure the PFT... it uses way too much power for it to be like...
I don't know.
Okay, hold on.
Let me get my... this guy.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
I just run in circles.
Run in circles.
Run in circles, man.
Doom.
Doom, guys.
Run in circles, man.
Oh my god.
Bitch.
They're so annoying!
They're the worst enemy in the world!
They're the most obnoxious thing I've ever had to encounter in my life!
And afterlife!
And everything!
And in my whole existence!
I think these guys are going to make me become the Joker for real.
Please, please!
No!
I pressed 4!
I think I accidentally pressed 5 instead of...
Oh my god!
There's still another one!
And I have no more ammo for this guy.
What the hell?
How did I take damage?
Was it me?
Splash damage?
Ouch!
Oh my god!
I'm flying!
What the heck?
BFG now?
I had no ammo!
What are you talking about?
Ammo!
I had no more BFG ammo!
I used it all!
Okay, hold on.
I think I was an idiot.
BFG is for when they are all spawned in in a big crowd.
You need to let them come into the area first.
Maybe chain gun.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
My W key wasn't working for a second.
Come on!
We're
so close!
I'm
gonna die!
Why is the BFG so bad?
Everyone is giving different answers so it's just so confusing.
But I did the best when I did it my own way.
So...
But also...
I gotta go to a meeting, you guys.
Oh my gosh, my Discord just was totally off.
Okey dokey.
Okay.
Man!
On the very last thing!
I'm gonna look up some guides on how to... what to do.
I'll see if after my meeting if I can continue.
Um...
The boss is BS, but I know you can beat it.
Good luck at the meeting.
Thank you!
What?
This is such BS!
What is this?
Oh my gosh!
It's just a...
Pew-pew!
Everything!
Give them out!
But they need to give you more ammo after you defeat all of them, I think.
Um...
The boss itself is kinda cheap.
Yeah!
And he's got the homing!
You first have to deal with so much!
And then he's got...
He shoots you into the air!
And you got the homing!
Everything!
And this and that!
Thank you, thank you!
Whatever the meeting is about, I hope it goes well.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry that I've been having so much stuff...
That interferes with stream.
But...
Yeah, like I said...
Wait...
I'm just gonna...
You know, I am gonna save this one as well.
Oh wait...
Oh!
I almost saved over the last thing.
Yes...
Um...
Just in case.
I think they give you everything that you need...
At the beginning of this.
But...
Um...
You know...
I will see you guys...
Maybe later.
I don't...
Like I said, I don't know how long this is gonna be.
If it's like a half hour to 45 minutes, then I'll probably stream afterwards.
But if it's a little bit longer...
Um...
And...
This is the last one.
This is the last level.
Please...
Right?
It is the last level.
And Draco's thanks for the 10 gifted.
Cause if it's not the last level, I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna stream.
It is...
Okay...
Mint phantom.
Because I really wanna beat it today.
Um...
Dang...
I was so close.
I was so close to...
I was like...
Man, I think I'll be able to beat it today.
I was so close.
I'm really...
Do you have a copy of Ace Combat 2?
Uh...
I believe so.
Yes.
Okay...
So...
But thank you.
Um...
Okay!
See you soon!
Go to your meeting!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go party and then I'm gonna go to my meeting.
Um...
And then I'll see you guys...
Maybe later!
See you!
Bye bye!
I'm so frustrated.
Hahaha!
Wow...
I was like, I can do this.
What the heck?
I'm so... what the heck?
It's okay though.
It's okay.
I'll get through the meeting and then I'll do my best to finish it.
Like I said, I'm gonna look up a guide.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and I'm gonna look up, like, so-and-so beating the final boss.
Surely a cool game.
I know!
Do it in the movie.
Okay, I'm just gonna not- I'll just keep streaming but I'll turn off my mic and turn off all the sound and you guys can just watch me.
How to beat area 27.
No, 28!
28, 28.
Okay.
Otomito!
Bye bye!